[Music]
[Applause]
Welcome
welcome go
the present day
excited
we nervous
I'm nervous anxious anxious
tired
but happy happy
welcome are necessary first
first first and hopefully first of
many conferences
with Chile
spontaneous applause please
[Laughs]
[Applause]
for those who don't know each other
On the other hand, it is noted that there was no rehearsal
those who don't know us my name is
Felipe Torres Ricardo Castillo here and
we are going to be your hosts
this day today and tomorrow both
days of the conference we will be
us standing up here
scenario I hope you don't get bored of seeing us
because they are really going to be with
we already complete
we call maybe they don't know us or
maybe they don't remember each other for a while but
because it is a pandemic involved yes
those two years I think he killed a lot
face-to-face community issue that but
we came back Now yes And for
who may know us somewhere
type of communities they are in
here actually present at the Chilean level
or who have arrived in other countries have
participated online, not in person
half like those of noudders
activities like North cool a jacatón
call everlook the goals of broil
livestream in general
I see raised hands of mentoring in
shout too
has been doing things for a while
community and this is the first time
we do something a little bigger
This is the first time, I hope many
many conferences we want
perform and how is the first
we want to tell a little bit about where it comes from
this idea and apart from wanting to make a
conference Because we wanted to do a
conference and how great and bringing people together
and make a big event and actually
some people told us that it was going to
be fun fun and easy i got old
like four years
the last week
true that's just to tell you a little
what we want we really want
do this many years ago the truth and
one of our focuses that we have is
precisely to the sea community Yes of
made one of the few main
Why we wanted to carry out the scomb
to be able to take and position Chile
view of the world with levels
engineering that is being done here
both technologically and
completely in the mode already going to
writing the web are doing very things
cool I don't know if anyone I mean but
especially specifically many of the
sponsors who came today are
doing pretty cool things and
It is quite entertaining to be able to do it and
show it out the focus really
as well as Mission and Vision It is that
we want to foster the community already past
the geographical limits of Chile
correct in fact today we are present
with nearly 600 attendees and many
parts of the world
but
but yes indeed yes no And as you
said about many parts of the world because
in fact there are assistants who come from
Italy Poland Macedonia
for us a dessert
true, thank you because
We can't forget something Yes that
there are many people who come from
in person here but there is a lot
people also who are watching us online
online many billions thousands
thousands of millions
the streaming that we are going to have
from here you are turning the page
leycom official and it is with cl point yes
they want it Twitter I wouldn't be angry
wonderful But it was also for the
official account of the page or that of
the YouTube account of so YouTube
dot com slash
But that sitting distributing for both
sides basically the page of and on the
official international law channel
Thank you for allowing us to use it yes Ah
Tuesday Tuesday I don't know where it is but
very grateful yes already although they are good to us
Seeing us here ahead and in
In reality we are here voluntarily without
no one targeting us
There is a great team behind the
If we have visible faces we are
us but
all volunteering all Core in
generally those who are in accreditation
those who are going to be outside those who are
Here walking around there are several
all this was achieved thanks to them yes and
For that reason we present to you the team
who is behind lamb I can do that
ask for a round of applause for them because
please please it is necessary because
Look
although we are standing here
up now and it's entertaining and we
we can move across the stage
that they are doing a Vega and they are
breaking the back are other boys who
You can see them because they have this little thing
Blanca So they are the team like this
really grateful for the time
of of the effort of the amount of
arranging the hours of sleep that they
we have taken them away so
truth with all my heart I can't see them
because I have lights but I know they are there
Thank you very much Yes no many thanks to
all really
[Applause]
and social networks are good there
Twitter mainly if the
They want to continue or something like that
Because they are always doing
activities and are participating in a
lots of things
ready we have the thanks to
our team that is essential and
We also cannot leave aside
who are acting as sponsors in
this
because everyone knows that too
sponsors are a fundamental part
so we can meet Yes and
do all these activities yes
So first starting to give the
full thanks to the sponsors
bronze type that we have yes we have
really the sponsors will be played
many have easily believed in
you
in doing this conference and knowing that
We were going to do something entertaining and
with them we were able to achieve good good
everything that comes outside everything that
They are seeing all this in here
wonderful amount of speakers that eh So
that they will wait for me for a second but a long time
thanks to our bronze sponsor
a spline a Julian a forgix synaptic
stripe a Jet brings
and laboratory
a big round of applause for them please
for having joined you and in the same way
We have our Silver sponsors
and
soft server to whom Well actually
They are here, they also showed off with
we are supporting us too and
we are one step further
give me a second huh
There it is, in addition to all this, we
we have another
So I want to give you a thank you.
super personal to the ICT people
precisely Gaby, I don't know where Gaby is
but Gaby has been a love, she has been one of
the most entertaining conversations
I have had I refer without disparagement to the
rest also with the rest of the
consortium But it has been quite
nice to have conversations with everyone
they so elastic from Gaby or Gaby
forgiveness by elastic balaz by Claudio inari
wave so truly extraordinary it was
one of the first to say I already
I help them, I accompany them in
this little little idea of ​​making a
conference
Adriana and who from Google I don't know where
They are small but
hey very grateful very grateful for
all the time all the time to deal with
chaos from the point of view of
sponsor with us like how
speaker so very grateful
yes no and totally grateful too
through Stream that is for consolation
and for Valentina I mean they are showing off
since the day before yesterday doing everything
possible to be able to hold the conference
to everyone and that we can
enjoy both online and in person
so really thank you very much medias
please give a round of applause
Hey and last but not least
[Laughs]
white sticks who would have said hey
I want to send you a thank you Walmart
Walmart from our platinum sponsor
It has been wonderful, I mean we had
we have been coordinating millions of
things the guys from bulmanes
specifically Erick Felipe How good
name Felipe well well done Machuca
Daniela López has been wonderful, I mean
The boys have played it, they put their
Stand they brought little things and everything in one
a period of time that is atypical for
for a conference of this size like this
really, thank you. It was quite enough.
atypical in fact they spent a lot of time there
things and a total thank you to
Ignacia de Urania Paula Ceballos by
all the work and disposition that
there was from Walmart
many many thanks to them later
come applause please for them
Thank you how wonderful
Hey for those who have left all this
process was quite entertaining right
Yes actually
At first it was only the
conference but one thing came to the
another and as if for some reason we
love to encourage us and on Wednesday
held a half where Walmart participated
Google and elastic with various talks and the
Thursday yesterday
the mitan drink was held
in the hotel next to Google with the talk
in English
That was some surprise to some
all the talks were in English but
in the entertaining part if at the end
but but for applause not for not for
hand because who was
what birthday
In fact that is a very important point.
because the metabs issue actually
or the mitan drink is the normal thing
we do
many years ago since 2015 in
reality and it reminded us a lot too
It is precisely that point of realizing
These activities and together with that is the
participation that we have with all the
communities Yes this this event that
we are doing
well the team I mean is an event
which is from and for the community that is
As we told you at the beginning
the same guys who are
volunteering, that is, even the girls from
There are people from the laboratory, there are people from
python people who said I'll join or
whether it's true it's a thing of the
community for the community So I
I'm very grateful for that and like
It reminded us a little of the concept of
how they entertained apart there was a
giant equal support because in the end
created a little this of I support you I'm going to
volunteers I am from such a community Let's
Let's go let's get it out Yes so
For this reason we want to give you a
specific thanks to several of
the communities we have been with
most likely if they have been involved
in the world of real communities
I think the community knows them
payton nine point five boys
of workana chile noudders that also
was with us a long time ago
participating with the livestream that
made the guys not great many many
thank you very much
a very entertaining podcast Yes very
probably in their in their little bags
have a QR of them so that
listen, they are really guys
I laughed a lot with them so really
If you have the chance to listen to it on
sometime they are super entertaining that
We are very grateful for everything
the entire team and in general the entire
community issue but
we cry we cry a lot yes already
we cried a lot we already got no more
There are certain announcements that we have to
do Yes or yes and that they are for issues of
logistics topics important topics me
I refer here at the conference
like, for example, I don't give them for
Please I'll leave you the floor at that point.
The first is the code of conduct, I believe.
that is the most important announcement and
here This is the basis of the conference
Can you scan it please This is the
code of conduct that we have in the
conference is the code of conduct because
governs the interaction of all of us
and the interaction we have
precisely the speakers or
precisely the speakers, the people
what sells the run the people who have
these labels that and the code of conduct
super simple it has a phrase that is
very short and conical
iconic iconic yes it is basically
ever to any event and after the
event that there is talking about and two
They say Oh you saw what that person did.
since that person is not you, it is
super simple but the version a little
more complicated is that as this event and
others seek to create a space and a
harassment free experience I am
reading for no eh The motto is that everyone
are welcome regardless of differences
gender race sexual orientation
abilities physical appearance or
beliefs we do not tolerate harassment under
no formal type and direct context or
indirectly
This is not negotiable. Thank you for that.
[Applause]
[Music]
and I tell him with him, with him, they broke me
with all the love I have for them because
because they attended today that no no
be that person it's not difficult to follow
This Ah, don't be complicated so
I really ask you with all my heart to be
respectful yes the first person we
It basically has to help make an effort
this type of behavior is you for
favor
And if things we hope it doesn't happen
nothing but if anything happens
thing to the people that you have
What to turn to are the people who have
this little thing this little thing Blanca the langer
white the credential is white and
all the guys on the staff I don't know if
They can say hello, they are there or they can't.
there are several that are out there
going around going around already with their
beliefs
you can turn to these people
for anyone safely
etcetera please I don't know don't get involved
in trouble don't get into any trouble
situation and can turn to people
Exact
we have several colors of credentials
the first one that we already named
From the white staff we have the
yellow credentials that are already
They realized they are yours and there are
an inverse of that credential that
end is not yellow black but is
black yellow good our designer
He didn't want to complicate things too much and he didn't
He thought so much that he said, No, we have already
the color has turned and that's it, it's one of the
stickers So you can identify them
especially because at the bottom it says speaker
On the other hand we have the blue one
that it is most likely that there are people from
press maybe going around there I don't know
scare
maybe they are going to be recording us quickly
and some may try to interview him
but please don't run yes yes no
do you want no please
And last but not least
we have the red credential that
For me it's pink I still say it is
pink
It was strange depending on the point of view to me
They told me I was salmon-colored.
baken so no idea with the colors
On the sponsors' side, they can
find them all outside or here
inside but if you want to talk to
They please let it not be here while
are giving the talks let's be
respectful with the speakers and with all
the people who left here
that one gets super nervous
Yes, but the sponsors can
find outside on the Esplanade there
inside or in the hallways which are the
general areas that we are going to be
occupying today and the day of
tomorrow that and since you mention the
Esplanade almost as if we had
prepared This is true now that
mention the Esplanade we have
certain spaces here that we have
access specifically
and one of them is like what I mentioned
Ricardo the esplanade and in the background the
Esplanade is the sector that is
encarped
the whole tent sector like
to have an interaction with
sponsors where we are going to give
where is the food going to be where can you
sit down for a bit to talk and throw away the
carve the cool sector there
after that sector The idea is that no
Let's move on, I ask you please, because
It is not the sector we have considered
for the event there are not many
regulations I mean we are not
following there so please no
Let's use the phrase there from the Lion King What's up
beyond the light beyond no we don't go
where we go further and to the side that
It was the Esplanade but we also have the
cyan cinema which is where they are going to be held
the workshops that start in the second
break or in the first
Break and these workshops can be
register on the page in point cl slack
works now clear the registrations
They came out like a week ago so
check if it's ahead
because there are limited places Yes, it works
Then he flew so that they could see me
I mean you can still register there
many super entertaining Yes indeed
we have about six
The following is what you could do
and I go
no and for the last space which is here
the theater and I really love it here
theater and I ask you something
with a lot of love they cannot enter even with
food or things to drink for two
reasons the first is that if it gets stained
floor and things like that with coffee or whatever
whatever we have to reupholster the theater
whole So no let's not do it and why
other hand and the most important is that yes
someone comes in with a coffee and trips
but don't pass by and burn someone
can cause serious burns
let's avoid any possible incident
that's like on the theater side, yes
emergency exits
those are those are the exits of
emergency if they are going to enter Do not
We can say that they do not enter or that they do not
leave ideally try to enter
rape now if there are talks they can go
outside they can talk they have with
bottom bracket but certainly there
They are very likely to be closed and
the same noise is when it sounds as if
it was a theater more less like it sounds
quite fed up So please occupy
the two over there bathrooms men's bathroom
there at the back women's bathroom here it goes
and unisex we do not have or without gender Yes that
It's not because we didn't want to because we don't
we could there is a Federal Revolution
There is a prestructure that we cannot
modify that there is something else that is like this
all talks have a translation
Simultaneously you can request the
headphones out there leave your meat
The headset comes when you return it
returns your card or passport or
passport, please take care of them please
favor
That's all true Yes indeed we have
now
our actual itinerary for the day
complete can be scanned in case of
who do not have internet for some reason
and you can download it in a PDF or
can see on the page directly in
where is the whole calendar yes we are
as a good conference we are a
a little late Yes so I tell them
We commented that we will regulate during the
day but but there you can see it
I mean and you can have the schedule of the
talks and what is going to happen today
our team at the bacterium is
working on updating the calendar
TRUE
That's all good with the talk, right, you
Ricardo saw
but wonderful but wonderful
all parts of the world and you know that
let's be but he's a guy to talk about
the gifts yes because we have gifts
Yes so speaking of gifts There is
enough the gifts the talks are a
gift we have gifts and those
gifts can happen at any
certain moment like now like now
fix something what date today Ricardo
February 33 how do you remember what is
someone's birthday happening in february
no sure hey
February three three F three
excellent excellent dear
[Applause]
Then if you can put yourself down here
we have some books to give away
we have no no to the shot it is not necessary
now but later coordinated in fact
we are going to get closer to be able to
give you the gift we have some
little books So it's the first gift
there are several subscriptions in our
Partners give us subscriptions There are
certain courses or there are not certain things
silver Yes there are some things from github I mean
There are several things that we are going to be
giving away within the conference And that
yes they have to be a little
pay attention so that they arrive on time
When we split the part of the
conference that is not speakers because
It's where we're going to give these things away now.
a lot true yes we have a lot a lot
gift and I think we have already talked
a lot
Besides, they didn't come to see us.
yes so that's all
advertisements So I wanted to ask you
now a big little applause for
receive our first speaker So
I don't know if Julián is okay Julián
wonderful if I can ask you for a round of applause
for Julián please
[Music]
Good morning gentlemen
How are we
I love that excellent energy, you have to
start with all Hey before it
Julia rises while you are your flavor
Julián does not know this part
we had not told him
but we wanted to tell you a little about
a little thing before I take you away
this and the truth why
a bit
Hey
no that's what we wanted to tell you a little about
Why is Julian opening the door?
conference And again this part Julián
They didn't know her, it was the year 2015 and
we had a very very galaxy
a galaxy far away a long time ago
very far away the year 2015 was us
we have a podcast it's a story ago
a long time and at some point
Julián interviewed in this podcast and
Julián tells us Oh, I'm going to make one
conference could come in Colombia
is seeing a little what I would do is How
I went there
We had a great time. I remember that
It was after the team talk
Petrusky was counting as doing
something with a disk with the audios and
Julián tells us we are here
dead for having enjoyed
But and we said
then from then on Julián a
little that helped us did not mentor us
helped during several previous events in
some time he said I can do his
your sponsor or your Champion in a certain way
so that they actually pass the
name Because it is not a whole topic, it is a
federated conference system then
you have to know someone basically
for the same reason and Maybe maybe with control
the the the mamonry we loved you a little
thank you very much because because of
truth not we to you not we of
made the main reason why
we wanted Julián to open the
conference was because he set the
conference bug can be done
in Chile and I also blame it on my two
sleeping hours No but grateful and for
that's what we wanted them to open
conference because truly one of
the important reasons for the
conference is to you that and now yes Now
yes, really, really, we retire
Thanks Felipe Thanks Ricardo what
such emotional words I start here now
I'm the one who's going to cry now
and we take this permission or you can
leaving there is no problem and this is a
great reminder that this not only
but the different vitaps that are
they organize and all the time that ends
We dedicate it to the community
community and that all of you
they are sitting there today very possibly
be in huaca talking
organizing in future editions of the
event but let's start with what I told you
I want to tell you today Today I am going to tell you
a story or let's start telling
a history of different languages
which are used to communicate between
systems
How one system communicates with another
how these languages ​​have come
evolving in the beginning
everything was chaos and everything was proprietary
We're talking back in the 80s.
xerox and these companies had their
own protocols and systems
coding but were closed until
that
she appeared in one they began to
appear standards committees that
They gathered to start deciding how they are going
to start communicating systems how
we are going to encode the messages to
to be able to send them and to be able to receive them
more standard they began to become
Popular are Macro systems
Unfortunately there is no one now
my favorite companies and I always wanted
working there developed xdr for his
song protocol
Remote a protocol that allows you to execute
methods remotely And if it comes
running for a long time
can be considered a technology
old man I think we are talking about 87
88 or so
but then a Revolution began and was born
the web thanks to Tim Barnes Lee in '93
the www became publicly available
and obviously
with it came xml who do you like that
from here Oops almost two people raise their heads
hand and that's because you know me that
He just raised his hand to help me there.
there's another one back there
obviously
xml is still a widely used system
text-based and text-based coding
systems began to be needed
communication on the web that are much
friendlier and with this xml rpc was born
where I can now communicate two systems
and execute methods using xml And that
it ends up becoming a standard
well known guided by many
called who still uses
two or three very popular in Enterprise
have worked with
subws 10 will seem very familiar to you
they have an awesome schema in xml and
They need a lot of tools to
generate code and debug that is a
problem
and that's why everything was chaos again and a
quite used chaos Because almost all
companies were doing all their
web services using
a better alternative an alternative
much more intuitive
Rest is born and we are already here in the
we are already using the http protocol
using http methods to
can
contact us so we can send
information still using excelel
but at least we have something more
easy to work with lighter clients
and we don't have to be working with
this type of generation tools
of code
and with this came our favorite
Jason in 2001 thank God for the
crocport Well before they started
developing this this standard means
javascript notation and
This was the one that began to dominate the entire
web communication topic
Jason became the queen and still does
it continues to be and I am sure that
it will be for a long time
The reason for this talk is to show you
that there is life beyond Jason and that there is
other things you can use
to communicate systems to implement
especially backend systems
then come with me to explore
protocols and binary formats in
javascript or mainly
the image you see in the background that is not
You can see very well. It is a very small island.
pretty with quite a few different
protocols and paths drawn is of a
book that I love called
designer intensive go to applications
by martin clepman and basically i must
give credit to this book
fourth chapter was the one that inspired me to
create all this talk I love it all
the topic of distributed systems
love backend company Ricardo no
I have no idea about colors or style or
sss or design but everything that is the
communication behind me
fascinates So I'm going to share with you
this
My name is Julián Duque, I am main
developedazgo Kate in sensforce me
You can contact me on Twitter That's my
website where I publish some things
of the videos that I record and of myself
work as an operative in supervisors and
As you had already mentioned, I am also
community organizer and suddenly
Finally we are going to give you some news
true excellent Adrian
what is this talk about let's
talk about coding systems and
encoding or other name they have is
the serialization and serialization or
also found in another language
Marshall in parce there are other terms
final scale represent the same for
end of the talk we are going to talk about
encoding and decoding is
convert a data structure into
something that I am going to communicate on a channel
specific and how can I get that
format and decode it to return to the
original data structure
Where are these used?
formats as such that we are going to
show today mainly packaging
data or in applications that are angry
intensive as I am going to store the
information in those databases
I need to have a format to encode
and decode for network applications
in this case it would be nap we talk about Rest
and we talk about rpc then here
we practically return to technologies
who have been working since the 80s
They are still relevant today and
in asynchronous messaging systems
messages that are already applications
where I will be sending great
amount of information through a channel
network that would be like a mixture of the two
previous one could be considered as
a kind of network databases
to start with these formats that
I'm going to tell you we have to obviously
Enter Queen Jason Then let's
talk about Jason we have a
Jason structure here on the right side
remember this structure very well
we will use throughout the talk
y During demos and benchmarks
For those who know a little about
soon from Don Johnson Dragons or games
role and this is a represents a
character I'm one of those nerds
love role plays
I have been playing for seven years and we have a
complex Jason structure we have
nested objects we have arrays
we have different types of data AND
Let's see how we can do these
transform into the other protocols
What are Jason's characteristics?
Jason is text based
that is, I write the structures
and I transmit them through the channel
network as text
Jason doesn't have a scheme when I
I am creating a structure I do not have
a definition object that tells me how
the properties have to be called or
what type of data are those properties
the outline is optional and I could
use technologies like Jason Esquima
to be able to force the way how
These objects are going to
serialize and essentialize but this is it
adds extra complexity and is not
necessary to work with Jason at
time to play with app
is highly supported and Jason
ends up becoming the queen is because
is native on the web Jason like his name
indicates it is a native object
javascript javascript is the language of
Browsers is the language of the web
Therefore Jason ends up becoming
the default standard for
highly used web applications in
what are Apps Rest
graffield and how we are talking about
remote communication protocols
also in Jason
Now let's talk about the formats
Binary serialization there are many
even several programming languages
they have their own
languages ​​I'm not going to talk about them now
has its own way of serializing and
serialize with marshall class there
others that have their own
Let's say methods and mechanisms, I
I want to focus on standards and
standards that are highly used
Of the three that I am going to show there is another
which is also very popular but
I personally don't like it So I
I said I'm not going to spend so much time on it and
It's very similar to the other one. So I left it.
On one side these three are pack tables
protocol buffers and open Who has
worked here with mezcal raise your hands
hands
one
Who has worked with protocol buffers
two three four five six seven and who
has worked with abro
also roughly five six seven
Perfect then I hope this talk
others like it because we are going to
learn a lot in this type of
formats very good let's start with message
It is a practically direct alternative
Jason Although there are other binary formats
based on Jason as
mink or Jason B packaging used
data like mongodvi so I can
encode Jason into tables binary format
pack is a pretty alternative
well-known popular has implementation in
more than 50 programming languages ​​AND
environments then highly supported
He has no outline just like Jason Yo
I don't need a definition file
to be able to serialize and to serialize
the final result of the object that I
I code with mesaspac is much less than
Jason so here we have the advantages
to work with binary formats and
These advantages come to everyone
If I have an iPad, where am I?
making few requests is not worth much
worth the profit I'm having
By reducing the size of the hair you will not
be a lot But what if I have one
mobile application Which obviously there is
several factors that include in a
mobile app bandwidth
battery
and I am sending a lot of information
between mobile app and backend
already the size of the hair of the size of the
package that I am going to send I am interested
I'm going to need something much more
small to optimize resources and if I
I am managing terabytes of data
obviously the amount of Data that I
I am sending the truput that I will have
or the bandwidth I am going to use
It's going to be much better when it comes to
use this type of formats
What are the disadvantages of working
with this type of binary formats no
They are human redable if I open a file
I'm not going to understand very well about mesaspac
What is happening and how
It works here in this image which is
taken over the site of fac tables basically
I am using certain bytes to
define what the data types are
that come next And from that
way I am taking away a lot of the
text of these braces of quotes and
information that is not necessary for the
time to define my package
We are going to use
the official message pack
can install it
administrach is the project officer
But there is a caviar, there is a note
since Jason is a native as he had told them
said in javascript engines
encoding speed and
Pack table coding is much more
Slow than Jason if we're talking Ya
encoding speed and
decoding
It is not going to be the best alternative but yes
we are talking about bangüi de trupu de
these other topics where I need better
resources here you can now use tables
so
I basically work with two methods that
imported them from the package I just
install these methods allow me
encode and decode I have the
same Jason object that I showed them to the
start this representation of a
role-playing character I'm going to
encode that object Then I have
a
buffer I have an encoded binary
and here I guarantee that the original object
be equal to the decoding buffer
I'm just doing a test
that what I am coding is
Exactly the same as what I am
decoding that does not have any type
of going to the later when
let's go to the benchmarks section
I will show the comparisons of the
package size of pack tables and
jason pack
now we come to protocol buffers and this
It's quite interesting and also
quite used and is becoming
very very popular it was created by Google
It's been quite a while but it started
return standard publicly I think in
2008 if I'm not wrong
It is based on a scheme Now I do
I need to have a definition file
of what my objects are going to be like
which ones I am going to work on in this case
file them
Messenger calls them
I can also define
services I can also define
methods of art and methods that I can
communicate remotely but let's see
the methods below
I already have many more types of data than
Jason in Jason for example I have
number and decimal number suddenly if I
Well, I have the point to the number but I
here I can define the floating point
I can define I can define integers
32 bit integers 64 bit I have one
best way to define my types
data
So that's where we start to have
advantages since I have the schematic
these values ​​that you see
right of the definition of the types
They are known as tags so at the time
I encode this binary I'm not
encoding the names
of the properties So I no longer
I have to send the names of the
properties by the network Then the
package is going to be much smaller But what is it
what happens both the one who creates the message
as the one who receives the message has to
have the same schema or a schema
compatible and there is already another topic which is
return of schemes I can go
adding
Fields To the schema as in a database
data When we do migrations and
we add columns there are certain rules
so that I can make evolution of the
scheme is very fast and here it is a lot
faster coding and
decoding that Jason by
algorithms it uses are supported by
code generation then
basically
old becomes new again
We go back to the time of that video where
we have to have tools that
convert a schema to code stops
to be able to work with them
but in the case of javascript no no
we have that problem since the module
Well, if it has a description of the language
Dynamic we don't have to use this
type of tools
And as I had told you, you can define
protocols for
remote execution we are going to use the
official package that is protags maintained
by Google and almost a little more
complex code is going to be smaller
But we need the package
We require the data structure that
let's code
We read the schema and load as such the
the message we want
use to encode in this case is
character we verify we can verify
The Data Structure pleases
that scheme that is valid that I am not going
to have any type of incompatibility
and I'm in charge of doing the coding
And decoding how I am operating here
with buffers I can now
see the bofer size and compare the
original size in Jason the size in
buffer and the same for decoding
So, we have
encoding and decoding
now let's go to my favorite
what is abro
It is a project by the Apache foundation
was born as part of hadou
as one of your data systems is a
Big Data management system
but abro became popular in another great
number of systems of the same
nature
abro is
very fast and very small Even in
some use cases much faster and
smaller the packet than protocol
buffers
It is also schema based and i
I have different languages ​​in which
I can define the scheme I can
describe the scheme as a Jason Por
That's why I keep telling him that Jason is the
queen I still need Jason even
to define schemas or can I use
a definition language to define
the interface of how to make my outline
I can also define a protocol for
remote communication using abro with
the same language in this case is in the
javascript ecosystem two packages
popular
avc and I open and they both have Future
parity the two are practically the same
This is the one I have found the most
updated but you can use the other one
who would be the project officer who is
thistle
and here we have a difference
definition of protocol bofers not here
we use the tags now it's time to
signaling and idealizing are based on the
order of how I am defining the
scheme So I no longer need to have
tags that requires some let's say
some challenges when it comes to maintaining the
evolution scheme if I am going to add
I have to add a property in
certain place I have to define that the
default value will be false for
I don't have compatibility problems
backward or forward compatibility
forward low to support
compatibility but everything is
perfectly well documented and supports
the two types of evolution
So how do we work with abro?
we import
the abro module we import our
Data structure that is what
we are going to encode and decode
we read the scheme of the system
files
we get the types from that
scheme So now with that type with the
types I can convert to a buffer
a binary that Data Structure or i
I can do the operation in reverse
from a buffer obtain the object
I also have a method to validate that
the object I have is let's say with beach
the scheme that I have defined and I am going to
ensure that the value actually
be what it is
then back to the use cases
that I had said at the beginning that it is
database that is the applications
network and what is the message
We see what tables pack by default or
It is natively supported by networks in your
lua scripting language and also
It is widely used in the ecosystem of
networks at catch time when I go to
store a complex object e.g.
in Jason on Networks for Catch Systems
We usually serialize that to a String
because networks do not support objects unless
that we are using another type of
data structures But if I
I'm only going to use it for Cash
Normally we make String the
String is very long and we have limitation
also space in networks with tables
I'm going to reduce that space and on top of that
I can put an algorithm of
compression if you want
So supported by redis Lua and by
another database called tres soldatas
Auro is also used in some
databases and platforms that are
go heavy like bitcoin
and Apachefina, which is a Server, is
a database server
Amazon no. That pachatina is fine Ewesa
here I made a mistake with the name sorry
if there is someone from
dws doesn't scold me here
in the networking topic it is used
by a technology called Ciro rpc Ciro
rpc makes the Ciro mix in cube with
pack tables for sending messages
protocol buffers is the main one
Gear peasy standard
It is one of those technologies that has taken
a lot of strength lately
time to offer guide pee and
modern as I told you the old comes back
be new again and quite Popular in
the go ecosystem but it is supported
for another language too and there is a very
good implementation of spin pc
stop and later I will show you
in the best marketing the example that
I have the protocol implementation
You now have your own implementation of
arpis and also as I had told them
you can define the protocol in
the definition file and the same
abro bookstores have How to serve the
in the ecosystem uses camel in the
javascript ecosystem the same
bookstore that I showed you has the shape
to create a protocol and that protocol
Can I ride a network transport?
to be able to carry out this implementation
PC
and for the Jean table system it is
where these guys especially shine
in Apache kafka Apache kafka above all
for the support that confluent has had
this one of this project has its own
register scheme, that is, it has its own
API where you can store your
different schemes associate the schemes
to an Apache Kafka topic and
automatically kafka takes care of
do encoding and decoding
of the messages I am simply going to
send any message from me
customer I will receive exactly that
same message on the server But before
that that message travels through the network
before that message travels through the
casca tail is responsible for lowering the
scheme do the coding send the
package and download the other scheme again
do the coding and deliver the
message then it's already taking me away
I have quite a load and I have also endured
by
let's say alternatives to kafka or systems
compatible with kafka as Panda network
they have the same support they have a
registration scheme where you can
put both protobofers and abro for
be able to send messages and
automatically kafka takes care of it
Auro is much more popular in the
kafka ecosystem and that's what
architecture experts recommend
to be able to send large quantities of
information here we are talking about
terabytes of data if I am only
making a chat Well suddenly I was
very but when we are sending a lot
amount of data is important and
us
we both use protocol
buffers there to the PC and I open for our
baby
with which we are going to
connect to receive events and
we use abro to be able to do the
encoding and decoding
sticks we have a large quantity
of events that we can generate
through the self system that's why
We mix the two in the same solution
and the results have been quite
good
Now it's time to see benchmarks now
I have them running because running a
benchmark is going to take us a while
but we will see results
So I drag here
then I have the examples that
had shown in the pack table slides
originally my jason file as
you see it in the in the three in the three
results
It weighs 279 bytes we see which tables pack it
manages to reduce to 217 by removing all that
jason clotter
as I told you if we have a great
amount of information this is going to give us
give a profit but when we are
talking about protocol bofers
difference is immense going from 279 bytes
making a lot of bytes or with open
279 to 85 almost where we are starting
Let's see the power of Why are we going to
start using these
let's say encoding formats
here we have a diagram a diagram
called coupon I'm going to look for it here in the
code
It is a very coupon-based scheme.
I think it's from shopify or shopify yes
I'm not bad ah no strike we have the
scheme both in I open with Jason and in
protocol buffers
and our benchmark takes care of
encode
using that scheme
carrying out many operations with
Random information then we see that
to decode we have native Jason
with Jason strings we have pack tables
we have protocol buffers and we have abro
here we see that the big winner is
protocol bofers when encoding
with the amount of one million 723
operations during the same execution
while
tables are left behind as there were
said the name is much slower and is
than Jason with 507 thousand operations but
When it comes to coding we see that the great
winner will be open with
823 thousand operations
for a second then here we are
seeing the big difference for
use these coding systems
We see you obviously working with Jason
strings in a native environment
javascript is also going to give us that
speed
In this example I have two running
using rpc servers
on one side
Gear PC And on the other side I open with two
implemented methods So let's
see the definition for that let's go to the
bofer protocol definition
here I am already implementing two methods
one is to roll a die and the other is to create
a character then I am creating
mitable my tool to play role
to roll a dice I am telling you
How many dice and how many faces on the dice
role playing games I have dice
different faces
and the character to simplify it
I'm just going to ask you to generate
the attributes that automatically launch
the dice and give me back the
attributes
and I am defining the same thing with
Auro defined the two methods in one
very simple way roll days that
returns an integer and breed and character that
returns a character that will be
suddenly appear very similar to
graffield but here we are talking now
of rpc and when implementing
I get the protocol
and I create a server from that
protocol and what I do is associate
the methods that read from the protocol a
roll daes Anon breeding and character with
javascript implementations
The same to get PC
It is more complex to reach the
definition
but it's the same I have exactly the
same methods same logic
and I am exposing
that service the two methods that I
I just created then those methods myself
I can now run them remotely
when reading the protocol from it
schema file I can create a
client and with that client I execute the
methods as if they were my methods
javascript here I am doing the remote
prose Your Call I am calling a method
remote that is on another server
through the same javascript as if
was local and the transport is already
in charge of coding and
decoding
the same on Gear PC I have the definition
of the protocol and I am getting the
methods that I am executing
the same way
This is giving me the result
send PC I have the result of the dice
serve 3 didn't go very well, believe me
character and with Abro he gives me back my
character and the dice went much better for me
I got 20 on a 20 die
have
another example here is both running
servers and the same writes benchmarks
for these servers to do the
character creation operations and
perform the operations of throwing the dice
but here in the protocol we see that I open
It is much faster when it comes to
send and receive information
protocol buffers
Well, when working with rpc for
that is so popular in kafka and that's why
becomes my favorite I open it
definitely the winner or at least
less in this use case and I'm already
showing that I'm out of time
I can upload these examples to you
let you see them more How to use
tables pays in a web application by
example AND how to use pack tables
also in a networking application where
We are going to encode and decode the
messages and how this was the last thing
I was going to show you latest messages only
use this where relatively
you are going to send a lot
information or receive a lot
information where you are the
owners of micro services so as not to
have schema conflicts then
for integrations in your own company
In your own projects it is very useful and
keep in mind that if you are
making evolution of the scheme keep
both forward compatibility
like backwards so that you don't go
to break the usability of clients
who are using your services And that
That's all Thank you very much Chile for
have me here
I hope you continue enjoying the
conference
and for those who are going to attend my workshop
tomorrow see you tomorrow
[Applause]
that we can continue continue to the square Ah
spectacular
no Julian wonderful wonderful
In fact I can ask you not to leave
still give me that you can disconnect
I mean but but because we want
this to the kids
Now yes Hey Hello Hello Thank you very much
really thank you very much for first
access Of course yes Hey, I'm going to tell you
just one little thing
You use this when you play role-playing, no O
This is not you
or it's not your way to create one of those
it takes a lot of time
what is your character today today
Today I am what they call a forever well
a person who always directs and does not
plays pitifully right now and
Above all, here I have Adrián who plays
With me I am directing you Alien the
game
and I have them suffering a little bit.
well as it should be with the
contextual someone else plays d&d or
We are both, right?
no one no one reacted with bardos Okay
enough
I like the neighborhoods Hey, I loved you
ask if I'm going to stay on top
please
spontaneous applause
unfeigned applause Wow what a blast
serious and this book to the first winner
The idea is that Julián delivers it
so please listen this is a gem
name
very good that wonderful
a hug a hug and a good applause
Thank you for having me here and
now let the others come
Now yes
and we're going to introduce our next
talkers
[Music]
you are entertaining yes we are going to change
tomorrow Julián is Julián tomorrow
we left everything Jason Hey
now our next speaker
next chalista our next
truth talker
what is an integration platform
for developers previously
He worked on Note source and there he is
a question
so I ask you a strong strong strong
applause applause truth for Liz for
please Liz for today
[Music]
[Applause]
What happened
[Music]
I found myself, I lived it and I learned when you
hits hard deeper
It serves to activate the day to day life
completely
the story ready a translation
automatic generated by the internet because
Lisa's name is Liz parodi
pronounced parody in Spanish and parody
and the translation they made appeared
So don't translate automatically
check your translations before passing
the production
Liz also organizes different events
of Colombian communities pioneers of
pioneers you were
we are adding titles that that so
Liz, from what I have clear, Alice
love to share knowledge and today
He comes to give us a wonderful talk
true wonderful that with all the
participation that has had, I believe that
he really likes to share how
knowledge not true but really
very grateful since you are here with
us today participating in this
first edition after also having
status in the organizations of the
Colombia is different from the other
Yes side is very different because
They are both very stressful
That's good. Hey then we're going to give it a
a new round of applause please to receive
to Alice and we got off the
scenery
Hello everyone Hello, you arrive with chile today
let's talk about new pictures or
features in don't get that
you should know I'm going to use some
terms in English because translating them into
Spanish is very funny because one has
translation Like parody for example
then there are better things than leaving it
in English
and
I come from Colombia today Colombians
We open The Great Talk I'm a developer
the previous company no longer worked there
and I am a speaker community leader
Evangelist by night and blogger Me
animals love doing yoga and
nature I'm like a little hippie
also and this is my Twitter if you have
Any questions if you want to talk there?
I will be sharing these
slides and this is Twitter
State Food I have been working for two weeks
there then it would be super cool if the
can continue
and These are the five functionalities of
New Yes that are relatively new
They came out last year and well first
the second is watch the third is Stream
accessores the fourth is arguments and the
five is a saying if I'm not going to translate
this because for example watch would be like
watch or Stream Access is like accessories
current or transmission accessories
So I'm not going to leave that to you.
English and I would like to know who here has
used these five functionalities
who has used three
Who has used a
there many many super then with
this talk is going to have like
basic foundations to understand
these functionalities
The first is test Runner or executor
evidence
we can all agree that creating
test and make tests for our code
It is very important but before
version 18 of no and there was no
framework uner within the arrives
to do unit testing Then
as developers we had to
import external frameworks like Moka or
yest to test surely
you use this type of primers
but adding frameworks adds
complexity to projects
environment configuration flows
work said and CD and expenses
general maintenance also not
It's always super easy to know how to do what
tools choose Because for example
some frameworks have configuration
fast and the effort is minimal to
start implementing but don't have
important things and that are also
useful as test support
asynchronous automoquin or simulation
automatic So for these reasons
included a test runner, a test runner
test inside New Jerez seemed like
a super good idea
so well you can ask about
why do we need another testner if the one
you already use
It works super well, it turns out that the test
native brunner at night and it is now
can be used especially when
develop a secondary project or
anything that is not a service
should a microservice and is needed
a quick and easy Runner test so super
ready and go
So how it works
upon entering
inside the night and the intention is
enable a limited subset of the
functionality provided by
most pro frameworks from one
light form Then as users
we can start doing in a way
immediate and add functionality
as long as necessary
In a nutshell now it can be done
tests do not arrive without any package
npm with the Note test module and with the
test script can be done Well on the CD
Life some basic searches in the air
with we cannot make assertions
associations are useful to know if the
test is good or not and as a curious fact
put like an inside was inspired by
deno because it does not have its own
So don't come, it was like Ah well me
I also want one and then they gave it
a person in the night well it was not
exactly like that but more or less and
also took Happy's Inspiration from the
Moca and yest app but yest took
Inspiration from things that should not be
do, for example, inject variables
globals automatically or run
code in different contexts since
may give results that are not the
expected
so well how it works I'm going to tell you
make a small demo and I will use
an application an extension of V scout
It's called rummy, it's super cool.
because you can execute codes and
commands in the rhythm then Well here
come on
you can see it well
Well then this is how they are made
three we import the notes module here
we have a do street to have
better error messages and we have to
James with chili is a conference
great so here we are just
doing the test that it is with chili it is
equals a great conference So
let's say to run this file
normally what I would do is Note and
the name of the file that is test and
We can see that there is a test and that test
it happens but I'm going to use it this
scot extension called redmi and
This same Command will be clicked
and it executes me. Here it is, there is a test and the
three step I will continue using then
like this extension
but for example if the test fails
Let's say you must confess bored
so here we can see
that is going to fail because I have expected it is
different from the current one was expected
great and then it gets boring
Well then it fails and here too
shows that it fails
You can also skip messages
Test and it also gets very tip test with
this Command with the command skip this
game will never run
You can also do subtests, that is,
test within others Test in this case
we are looking at one equals one and
that two is equal to two
and for more advanced features of
Test can be done with
modules for example interpretation of
modules with proxic and Smoke spine with the
synon Spain package in Spanish would be
like spying and hitting then like
let's not leave them in English and Snapchat
independent would be snapshot assertion
Some final observations are that the
common function formats
test as promise rejections
error throws return
callback not invoked all that is thrown
as errors and for testing only
the notes module is imported and to
run it with node and the name of the
file and to run many tests
many files at the same time
It is done with Note script test and the
options
now the second functionality which is
watch this I think it's one of my
favorites what it does is restart
automatically the app at night and
is when it detects changes in the
files
last year the official account of
girlfriends asked
like what was the tool that you
they found more useful to develop
and to write javascript in day to day
day
and the response of most people
can not Demon here who has used
no Demon Ah yes there almost all super
It is a super popular package it has 5.2
millions of weekly downloads and what and
for those who haven't used it what it does
is that it observes the changes of the
files and immediately restart the
application
then watch by default
will observe the entry point and
any required or imported modules and
to look at a specific route you do
scripted script watch script
It is also important to take into account
which cannot be combined with check ebal
interactive in the
and it is done this way, it is very simple Note and the
file name
Now let's look at how it's done
here we have
This is a super simple Hello words here
I am using typescript Hello world and
we are printing the message on the
console then
walk this is run with Note watch
here it is I have days not registering because
is a typescript file and the name
from the file
so here we can see a hello world
little guy over here and it's going to stay
running because he will be watching
the changes. So for example if I
I change this here I think that in Chile it is
says
cachaipo
so here we can see that
automatically restarted from cachaipo
a little slow
[Music]
Right now it was working perfectly
I promise well I don't think I
Good either way
Well now the third is Stream Access
now you can do more filter and
reviews in streams
for those who have not used
streams streams have a
reputation for being difficult to work with
and much more difficult to understand but
It is one of the fundamental concepts of
night is already left, yes they give a lot of power to
applications is a management method
of data used to read or write
input in your output or inputs in outputs
sequentially, that is, it is a
read file handling method
writing network communications and
any type of exchange
end-to-end information
efficiently which makes the
streams are super powerful is that in
Instead of having all the data in the
memory and then be processed as
It is done in a traditional way
strings read the data fragments
piece by piece
processing Your content without saving it in
memory this gives us great power
to process large super files
heavy since the size of a file
greater than free memory space
So if there is no free memory, it is not
can process any file and paila
well what a pity paila it's an expression
Colombian that means everything wrong Ah
well yesterday I learned how to say that in
Chilean I think something like that is cool
like superquatic then well
then there when everything is superquatic
streams come to the rescue
Also for example let's take the examples
of streaming services like
Netflix or Spotify or Twitch they don't give you
They force you to download everything to start
process the data AND so that they
They give you fragments it's a flow
continuous data stream that allows
users start consuming the
information immediately
that's why it's called streaming and streams
They are not only useful for super files
great but also give the power to
composability in code and design
with composibility means that several
components can be organized in
different way and give the same
result
so good because stream basically
For two reasons, the first is
memory efficiency since it is not
You have to put all action in the
memory for it to be processed and the
Second is time efficiency
which takes much less time to process
these files and there are four types of
streamings do not arrive the first is are
streams in which we can write and
does with the function F create by Stream
It is also where we can streams
in which they can be read and done with
efes create Bridge streams duplex are
the two streams files in which
can read and write and transform
modifies or transforms the file by being
read or by writing in them an example
is to unzip files one can
write compressed files and read
unzipped files
Well now I'm going to show you what it is
new streams have existed a lot
time in nouja and I look forward to what's new
The new functionality is that now
you can do map filter and reviews in the
streams
so here I have Maps
It's like the four types of streams that
explains to them to read and the spring
we will use to
the promises
well and then here we are reading
these four numbers 1 2 3 4 and we are going to
make a Maps from and multiply it by
two and here we are reading these three
websites
with chili and stakehol and we will deliver
like the results
By running this we can see that
multiply the numbers and already super good
now filter
It's the same as the streams and we are
creating like small fragments of this
Stream But this is a small example
then they are the four numbers we are going to
filter by whatever numbers
mayoradas and we are going to print it in the
console
here we can see there I lost it
here we can see
Yes three and four are the numbers that are
greater than two
and reviews
also the two same four numbers and
let's add the current one plus the previous one
and we are going to show the results here in
the console
and the result is 10
Well now you can do more
filters using streams
well the fourth the fourth functionality
is to argue that it serves to analyze
the arguments in cie light
There was a big discussion within
the contributors at night and it's because
There are many packages to analyze
there are arguments in heaven to create
programs in the skylight And what it was like
possible that it did not exist as anything native
within So as developers
we have to import super files
super popular packages like commanders
to create programs along the lines of
commands or to parse arguments
Commander has 108 million
weekly downloads is super popular and
what it does is that it takes care of analyzing
arguments in options and arguments
Command shows usage errors
for problems and implement a system
of aid and jarts has 78 million
weekly downloads is also a
very popular package and helps to create
command line tools
interactive analyzing arguments and
generating a user interface
elegant then basically Commander
and yards what you do that how to analyze
the command line and good facilitate
working with the command line
The useful Point Parts ars module was
included within Nueva yeguest the year
past and what you are looking for is to add to the
useful.parzars assistant for the
line argument analysis
high level command instead of
interacting with processes directly is
say that it takes all the
argument specifications
expected on the command line and
that returns It is a structured object with
all options analyzed
parcer parser has not executed
functions did not buy types does not allow
define types and subcommands do not
They can take different options
main command and Rayito Rayita points
the end of options
Now I'm going to show you how it works.
argument partners
so
I have
the notation module and I have options there are
four options no
it was like damaging
I have a dancer nationality name and
Gamer So these are all strings
these And these two are booleans and here now
I have the options and I am going to print them
on the console
so here to run this file
make note of the file name and
I'm going to pass the options on the line
commands so that it is analyzed then
the name will pass Liz the nationality
Colombian and I love to dance so
dancer is going to happen but I'm not a gamer
So nothing happened this
will be true by default
So if I run it we can see that
That's how it is, name Liz, nationality
Colombian dancer and that's all
arguments parsed with these options
to do exactly the same thing Before
I had to do all this so I knew
that
import that from process point Art had
to replace a split and this
well it is let's say much more complicated
harder to read and you already have open the
doors to possible vulnerabilities and
errors Instead like this or this way
how to do it now with the options
It is much easier to read and everything
and something very cool
something very cool is that the native module
will not replace existing packages
but it will allow them to capture
easily these arguments in the
cielike and perform complex operations
That is, there is no need to replace or
comader but this gives you more
functionalities
so the air
and the last functionality that we are going to
see today is a saying a saying is a
http client one point one compliant
with New Yes specifications and
which is written from scratch and
you represent the evolution of the stack
http at night
let's see if it can be seen big
well that's what happens to me for having the last name
wall it and because that always happens to me
things like that but well
So I really like the http where it is
Well, I like a saying, where does it come from?
name is one point one that can be
read like eleven in javascript and a DJ is
11 in Italian and it is also a
reference to stranger things then
that's where it comes as the name it is
as a unique good. Then why does a DJ?
You may wonder why I am going to
implement another http stack if the one
It is already being used, it works super
well actually the http stack of
neje has design problems
fundamentals that are impossible to
resolve and break all the Epi there
It also has certain errors and
performance limitations and
security that cannot be fixed without
affect millions of users both in
the client as the server since they are
deeply linked
the team behind a saying is
committed to creating
a stack that is fast, reliable and
meets all specifications of
neoyories
some important features is
which has a keepa Life by default
So you don't have to configure any
key life agent has planning
lifo what is Last in first out and this
Help with wait times
no it does not have a pipeline by default but it is
can configure has connections
unlimited and can be redirected
gets
Now how to make a muking with a
said there are several important things for
in a saying how to make Proxy
redirects and how they are done
muquins So in this case I'm going to
concentrate only on How to do mocking
then a saying reinvents the
http primitives and builds
directly into the sockets
And then for this reason Some
mocking approaches like nok not working
but it comes with its own
some examples we are going to use
puppies
then well
here we go the puppy customer and he's going to
being something simple is only important
a list of all the dogs here
I will have a list of all the
images these are like Yes here the
images and here we are seeing that there are
some error that throws the error
and I'm going to do three tests here, the first one
is that it should return a list with all
the breed of dogs Here we are going to look at what
there is the bloodhound and the Chihuahua and also
here
Let's look at what, well, let's throw one
an array with the entire list of images
and if there is not the third tea it would be
that throws an error then there are three
tests are very simple and here is how
Then the mock agent is
the basic entry point of the system
of muking of of
here we have the internet that what it does is
build the system so that we are going
to serve as a replica in memory
of remote services and here the Replay that
will respond with subs yes it works
here we are going to see that the image is
valid with a king and good And here we go
pretend there are three images and well
And here it will also throw us an error
if you don't find it
So let's see how it works
And then we can see that there are some tests
there is no internet well then
well that's how it works
imagine what works super well
And finally, since we are talking about
puppies I present to you my puppy
I found a small one like this in the middle of the
Forest grew giant like a cow weighs
more than me is very big then This
is my dog
and well some conclusions I would like
know what the functionality or the
file that you liked the most if you can
make a tweet to State by hq and I will tell them
I'm going to remove them I'm going to be reading
so it would be super cool to read them and
These are some features
experimental that are probably
They are going to arrive late at night in the
The next few years are without hooks diagnosis
channels
crypto Api web streams and was and then
let's say the don't arrive team is
very committed to getting things out
super cool and good Oh well And another
thing to keep in mind is that all
the functionalities that I just mentioned
explain are experimental then AND
like and these too and like all the
experimental things don't get there it's good
I don't know that it hasn't been used in
production
And finally if you have any questions
These are my contacts. Many
thank you especially thank you all
you and the organizing teams
[Applause]
run run run run
It's just that this thing about getting out of the other please
let that loud sound be heard again
applause
[Applause]
Hey, thank you very much, Liz Static.
chat
was consulting about the word
actually aquatic and good like many
idioms in all countries there are
words that have many meanings
depending on the context in which it is used
then a lot of incredible things happen
is generally doing all the
new parties everything that is coming out
Yes, as if it were a language with
a whole foundation behind you say
Exact
Hey, I wanted to tell you a lot about that.
thank you if you want to stay with
us now because we are going to do some
a few ads a few
Real reminders Thank you very much
for your really entertaining talk
thank you very very much
One more applause, join us
[Music]
Hey little ads we have
now a little break like you
you know the hours go by a little
So we have a small break of 20
minutes we will return at 11:40 here
That means that the orchards also
They will leave at 11:40 and first
first of all
basic reminders reminders
again, do not enter with food, leave your
headphones please to the exit outside
is doing a outside is doing a
horrible heat so please
Stay hydrated and use the bottle that came with it.
in the flashback she is very pretty
then and keeps the water very cold
some would say crazy hot baby yeah
totally but yes we were really 20
minutes were actually 30 but as
good Chilean better to say 20 because for
that we reach 30 important I know
that there are people who suddenly are
sitting there there are seats up here
looks great
But that can come down later
for one that is not so high that it is not
have to deal with so many stairs
complicated But also why why
I mean the people who arrive
late sit there don't have to pass
up to here complicated so yes
they want wonderful that true In fact
yes I'm going to see if I have something in me
pointer Yes the workshops and that
in a little while and that they are free to
action see you in twenty minutes Yes
thank you very much enjoy yours
and the other talks that we have left
applause So applause for you
Also thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
we have many conversations left for a long time
and here come some questions for
you as an audience
are happening
first someone was out at the booth
of Google
nobody someone passed
who was there can say
already
Can someone get me a sticker of
Chrome or a Dinosaur sticker by
please because they won't let us get down from here
I step there and they challenge me But someone does this
this doesn't exist it doesn't exist I'm
asking
there we have there we have this
dinosaur Thank you very much
no we don't have a backpack
We didn't have a backpack.
They went up, they put a t-shirt on us and we
They said you don't take him down from here, don't you?
They let us go out neither there nor here
Hey someone raped before going with you
claudinary spaces because there are
some very nice stuffed animals
Can I ask you for one please?
is going to disappear
look how tender he is very cute
stuffed animal Hey, you're wonderful, this is
amusing
so beautiful, I loved them and many
thank you
Hey before we leave with our
next speaker and we are fine
true Yes I have a small announcement
there is a key here
I would not love it
there is a key with a wolf
That's why I say I would love to say Oh
I want to tell myself well
[Laughs]
hey but that's it we're going to leave it here
because if it belongs to someone I mean
can come after talking to
we at the beginning have to respond
some questions
is that we have raised the level
If someone wants to get it back they have to
answer some questions
That's it Those are the ads save
This later we coordinate
Now if we start in the official ones we can
present to our teeth But for
supposed
Hey, first I want to ask you for a
gigantic hug for our
next speaker Jorge Rubiano for
favor
[Applause]
[Music]
and here is another point
what Colombia
it has taken all the beginning
Jorge there was a developer from Colombia
has been developing for a long time more than
15 years and within that he has seen many
changes in technologies at the beginning
I did programming based on flash flash
someone knew flash use flash
I heard pure Yes
but with Flash you could do many
things
Yes, later they began to remove the
medium
and Jorge made fire if I'm not mistaken
also with Flash and today in its
hobbies is dedicated to developing
games with javascript Exact
technology changed but not passion
and that too Listen to the Bible
TRUE
again So I want to ask you for a
a gigantic applause gigantic applause
for Jorge and we get off
we leave like this
Well, good morning to everyone,
our companions told them on the day of
Today I come to bring you the related topic
with games in reactivate what project and
fiver, this is roughly the combination
between two large bookstores such as is and
react as I told you my name is Jorge
blonde, I'm from Colombia currently
I work at a company called Boyer x
eh This is my Twitter for those who
want to follow me too because this is
Laurel from my page where you can see
many of the projects that we are going to see
Today is the agenda that we are going to
drive very very fast let's see a
methodology I follow for development
of these resources such as Toys
we are going to talk much above Real
Yes to have a little context let's go
to see some games developed in
reality
I say only a reaction I have called them
generation 1 games generation
3 that do not require reactive fiber let's go
to speak very superficially about Trio is
then about reacto and fiver we will see
a comparison
we are going to see the fourth generation of
games already developed with reactivar and
finally a demo and conclusions
First I want to share with you
a methodology that I have followed for the
development of these resources which
called breakable toys the idea behind
of this of this mythology is that we can
use a personal project that is
similar in toolset but
does not reach a system that normally
it would be seen at work I think
many of you have done this
soon they will not know him as breaka volks
soon they know it as cipray or se
issues of this type but the
The purpose of this is to be able to test
issues before they are
stable example I give you an example
some of the games I'm going to play for you
show were games that I developed with
the beta version of riac before the
inclusion of hooks for example Then
The good thing was that when Hughes went
stable because I already had knowledge of
this case of those ninepi in
They have basically been focused on
learn new technologies libraries
through personal projects in your
most games does not mean that the
Toys have to be games, they can't
make a breaka volkshoy to learn
I don't know the access Well a new Pía or
learn by making a tube for example in
this case basically as they told us
our companions I come to the world of
Flash and well when I came to the world of
from the web because I had to learn how
a Canvas works how it works
css example to be able to do all the
part of transitions and how I did it
via breaka voltois
as Charles told them about react and
fiver and more than anything I want
put a context for those who
have not managed
riad que reac basically reac is a
library that helps us create
interactive user interfaces
simple way in this we can design
simple views for each state
our application and as you know react se
handle updating and rendering
efficiently the components that
something very important is required, which is
the last paragraph is that react too
can be rendered from the server
using Note and also potentiate
native applications with Jacky Remember
well at the end of the day what
example when we are on the web
remember that we not only have react
We also have react true which is the
that at the end of the day is the one that
interpret the ex to be able to render it
in this case on our website
some area games as I told you
I want to share these games with you
you because I want to show you the
evolution I don't want to tell you in one day
one day I woke up and said I'm going to work
react fiver was not all a process
learning the first thing I want
show you are some very games
simple ones in which I wanted to learn
Basics of Real as it was
the management of the State a component in
that time the use of saving functions
a class-based component create
scenario completely in css here
You will see something very very interesting that
second, the use of energy saving functions
class-based components these
games date more or less from 2017
when still to have the state inside
of one component we required more
class-based components I don't know if
Remember the ten point Good before
hooks
some games I'm going to show you very
above we have in this category for
example a game called teacher which is
basically a reverse calculator
Instead of describing the equation we
What about Well in this case
gives the answer another very simple game
It is for example Game's calculator that
Also in this case we have to give into
based on this objective and with the buttons
What we have here basically gives the
answer these games are
completely made in react and well
all the scenery or if you can say
They are made in CSS
let's see now the second games
second generation games
generation are games a little more
complexes in which we not only have
Lan react but we also have in this
case a backen part in this we have
games like Mister Square we have a
game like any of you that I have played
some Windows 95 game suddenly
remember that it was a very game
interesting this game I wanted to do this
version in react so to learn more
about state management and animations
So as I said in that category
we have games like Mister Square that
basically it is a very simple game in
that the user has to move this
character from one side to the other and well yes
they realize this is done
completely in Canvas and I mean in Canvas
in css with html nothing from Canvas yet here
we are not using any Canvas at all
a moment then we have another game like
this game also basically what it is
search is that we have this character
what to move and basically what we have
what we're going to do is eat this mushroom but
Well we have to be careful not to
that happened to us there a flower ate us
these games I come back I tell you they are games
second generation one of the games
second generation that were more
complex to do but it was very
challenging was a version of Parcheesi
in react in Colombia this game is
You know how the parquet floor is, I understand
which here in Chile is known as ludo
here basically what you are looking for is that
two three or four users can play
on a certain board, in this case I wanted
not just make the gameplay of the game
but also allow gameplay in
real Time so here we have
example the little game I'm not going to play
against another person but to do it
So how can you figure this out?
scenario is made 100% in CSS and
basically the entire state is
driving with real good and some some
some state management library
below
ready So ​​these are the games
of second generation now let's go
Let's see well in this one in this one that I wanted
learn so go deeper into the
knowledge of react especially new
functionalities that at that time
we had suspense hooks among others
the other make use of websockets to
real time gameplay though
also actually uses libraries
As a fool, I also improve the
knowledge of that is and css3 the other
also understand how service worked
worker to be able to make an application
100% pvp as you realize
I am showing the applications in this
case as if it were a native application
because basically remember that with peo
If you like, we can install the application and
also make use of authentication
through social networks using
passport
third generation games in these
games as you can tell are already
games that are a little more isometric
which take advantage of a little more
the depth in this category we have
games like longcad we have games like
cosol and games like hocus So why
For example, a game like long Cat is a
very simple game in which we have
this kitten and what we have to do
is to move it and make the whole body
of the kitten complete the the the stage
this again is done with css here
css and real Yes but all the yuai is
made with css other games a little
more complicated like Sol in this case already
It's a slightly more isometric game.
all that animation you're seeing
new sss here for example well I'm not going to
start solving that level because
always long Here we will let it
solve only then here basically
that was used to make the
depth of the famous Zeta Index and
basically depending on what element
I want him to be behind or in front of him
I change the Index that is a trick that
It can be applied not only on the web but
also in games and one of the games
which I consider more complicated in this
category was the game called hocus
This game basically what you are looking for is
that we have to solve a world like
You can see those are figures
impossible and here basically they do occur
count now the cube is ahead this
It is also made with CSS right
so here basically came a point
in which I said Ready, I already managed to understand
I understood the most about CSS
do what I could that that's in
this case to make questions in 3D in
this third generation Well, I wanted
deepen your knowledge of hooks
creation of custom hooks Remember that
with riat we have the ability to create
Personalized books also make the
using animations like react viag
Sprint is also part of the ecosystem
of react fighter that we are going to see handling
of sounds allow the creation of
custom levels and new options
for the pw
but as I said, I've already reached that point
point at which I had developed games
isometric and I already wanted to make games
a little more complex in this case in 3D
And that's where it appears
It is a library that allows us to
generate 3D graphics Remember that when
end of the day that generates those graphs
in 3D it is web and he and with Trio Yes what
allows us to write the
code with javascript that in the end well
send it to the web so stop to do it
maybe if we wanted we could create
custom shaders for power
interpret by a web Then
contracted as you know can be
make interactions in 3D and
questions of that type but how
he said well he was still working at riack and
well I'm still betting on react and I said well
there will be a possibility in which we can
use react and 3DS at the same time
The answer is yes we could have
added a Network to the Canvas and do it all
directly but in that search
the perfect bookstore appeared
called reactive
Reactive at the end of the day is what
calls a real render the idea behind
of a render is that we write
code in GSX and then the data is
become something else in this case
particular in a scene between two
So for example when we
we are on the web and we are studying
GSX for example one day a spam Remember
that in the end it becomes a real
Creed Element and at the end it is that compiles
Well, to our html reactor and fiver it was
created by Paul Hersion Also known
for this handle on Twitter which is a
little complicated to say he is founder
and manager of Point Andrés who is a
code developers collective
open let's see that in the ecosystem
of reacto and fiber we not only have
reactivate as such but we also have
a series of helpers or good libraries
using a library called
Drake ready and also other libraries
for transitions like
riajes
Let's see a comparison between and
reactivate
So next in this case it would be
right from your screens we have yes
we have an example written in
estuary in Río Yes What a shame in this case that
we are seeing we import the package
Friday is wide a little more or less
there is a little more so basically
here we import the library After
So we set our camera to
This case makes a perfect camera and here
I'm going to read the scene one way
different, that is, I'm not going to read the code
as it is in the order but a form
different so that we see this In
comparison with reacty fiber as if
You realize here I have a scene like that
scene I'm adding that mech
month at the same time has a geometry
and some material that we have up here
So tomecha is composed of a
geometry and a material in the case of
reaction we have different types of
geometry we are using
for circumferences for even
complex geometries
We also have materials here are given
account I am using a material
normal type material this material
something interesting is that it has its own
light that's why you will see in this example
that I am not applying any light to the
scene so it is not necessary later
Here we apply our render by
default we made it web type
here we add a listener
to listen to this change
change the one on the screen we add the
render in this case the html document
here we have a set Animation Loop this
this is typical of of is but before that I don't know
If any of you have handled the rich
es Animation frame Remember that with the
spare Animation frame we can is like
It has been a replacement for the interval
but the performance is much better
It's much better and at the end of the day here
we have an event of type a Windows that
He basically listens to me when I'm
waiting for the screen to scale
scene basically This is the example
between two and them now we are going to see what
same but in this case in this case the
left side of your screens we are going to
see it with reactive fiber then
initially we start from a component
called app can be called From any
shape does not mean that it is that way
convention we use a Canvas this
Canvas and where we bring it we bring it from
react Fighter After that how
You can see here we have a
component this component is a
component that thinks it is called of type
Box and this component has a series of
issues the first we are using
Just remember how good we are
using a Just we are doing a
reference directly to that element
In the case when we do it let's say
a DIF we are doing it to doom here
we are doing it directly is to
Canvas we spend this one a month because
it is important it is important to keep in mind
Keep in mind that when we want to do
animations with reactivar we do it
directly in this way with using a
hooks that is called use frame that comes
being in this case our friend being
Animation Loop below this one too
The rich one is Animation frame and here
and here we encourage it why I say it
because I also had that one that one
that problem when I initially tried
use a state I said I will not create
a State with this one and I'm going to animate it eh No
Remember that this at best
cases runs 60 frames per second
So that would be very bad for him.
performance now another question for
keep in mind is the following as
you know when we are
creating a custom component in
reac so that reac knows that it is a un
user created component
first letter is capitalized true
So when you are in html
they are writing a dip they are
writing a spam And that comes in
lower case if you realize, look
let the elements here in reactive
they start in lower case we have our
merge and our Geometry and be in
lowercase and another important question
never mind them because these are
elements of the Canvas yes in this
case of free fire I give you an example
when you guys are writing and sex
normal rendering in doom you
It's never that important It's never that important
important in a spam reaction or in
This real case understands what it is
something native to the browser
something else important is that well
It seems to me that they iterated on
reactive is relatively easy because
here we are taking advantage of the
reusability for example I am going to create in
in this case a new element let's say another
cube this cube we are going to change the
position So in this case if they occur
account I already have another cube and here we go
make another cube here and we have it in this one
case So you already realize
in a matter of five seconds you already believe
in this case another component based on
another component And how like you
know in the world of react to not only
in the real world the world of
component-based libraries when
we need to customize a component
we do it through props like
I told them in this case with with reactive
fiber We also have a series of
bookstores or ecosystems well
ecosystem has a series of libraries
so that they allow us to encourage and
make things much more important
easy one of them is the bookstore
known as orbi Controls basically
Let me let's manipulate the
camera So if you notice there
I'm manipulating the camera So on
In this case I am not saying that it is not possible
do can be done but it would be a
a little more code ready and the good thing
in this case of reactive is that we
knowledge that you have in this
case in reac you can apply it here in
this case in the creation of components
ready
Let's see some series of games
this category as I told you something very
important me always and not me but
It's advice you always have to start
with something small yes I mean I didn't send myself
make a very 3D game a little more
complex because otherwise it would be frustrated
So in this case I made a game
relatively very simple this
It's basically a Soko Bank So
we have this zocón here so this
software basically what you are looking for is
that the user has to move this
little box but this little box if you realize
falls and the whole stage turns on us
I confess I tried to do this
in css And then I failed at the end of the
day I said well yes I need one
tool that can tell the group
the whole group come turn and in that
case because in that case the solution was
react free fire here the solution is a
little complex that we simply have
as axis the box lower the box
do them in this type of games as
You realize I'm going to make a simpler one
because I don't remember how this one
solve basically we have
here and here what we have to do is move
the box ready below here
you are using reactive and so do
What we know about react
this is the game called
It is relatively simple another game is
the so-called colorite basically
What you are looking for is that we have a cube and that
In this case, the cube has two faces, one
face with one color and the other face in
white then The idea is that the cubes
we have to paint them white with that
cube with for example in this case with
a yellow color but avoid it
the white cube also took away the color
back to the cube we had Then
For example, in that category we have
example this
and here basically what we do is yes
You realize I'm spinning this cube
I already solved it ready here I do
very funny is that in quotes
because here I am not using a
physics and collision engine still in
In this case I had to teach him the game
How to climb stairs or this is funny
how I teach him this game
know that now you are uploading a
ladder then there it is
solving alone Yes because well sometimes
solving them is complicated for me. So this
basically it was thank you Well in this
case to react Fighter that allows us
Well, make this type of animations there
there we solve it ready So ​​these
These are the games that I reached the category
of reactivar But today
I want to share with you a new
game that I am making very simple
which one are we going to do a bowling alley then
in this case with with Yes Remember that
brought full allows us to make a scene
in 3D but it also allows us to manage
physics and collisions So let's
play a little game of bowling in the
which ones are we going to take into account?
So do all the physics part and
collisions so here I have a
project then I start this project
with a fragment I am going to focus only on
I'm not going to show the react part
example how I calculated the score and another
type of issues because it is not
necessary here I start with a fragment
we know we can write a
fragment of also this way but
I like to make it more explicit So
In this case initially, a game
of bowling he has has a score
So that bowling game has a
score we are going to pass in this case the
state of the game that is in game State
Then we're going to take your turn. Well,
we need to know which player has the
shift After that we have to know the
the state of the ball is whether the ball
it already fell in this case where it fell fell in
the gutter or fell at the end of the
scenario then here if you realize
We already have if you can see what a shame
if it is reached
I don't see anyone I'm talking
only then here in this case here
We now put something very important that
we have to put is the state of the
Pins So as you know Well
In this case we need to know if the
Pins are up if Pins have
fallen also that that because it requires it
In this case our friend judge is
game then there we were the state
from Los Pinos What are we going to do?
popular good the 10 Pins bowling alley
I don't know how to play bowling, I had to learn
here because above all for him
score then we are going to put a component
of type game message this component that
he is going to tell us he is going to tell us the
different game messages in this
case will tell us when a strike
when there was when there was an esper in short
After that we are going to put a component
of type game statistics that component
what is he going to show us is he going to show us
who won in the end in Then in this
case we pass our Players and makes
It has Well basically the State has
So if you notice here
it automatically showed it to me but no
should less shown because it was a
finished then for that we put
our Game Over we make a conditional
here and in this case we make the value
So in that case it is no longer
showing what you are seeing
is
normal reactx
now let's start doing this
renders in a Canvas for that we have
a scene type component that
is the component at the end of the day is
rendering a Canvas as you can
realize we have some shadows so that
apply shadows and we have a
camera settings After that
Well, here we do need lights. So
we are going to load a component of type
lights After that we are going to put a
suspense component Because
we need the type component
suspense because we are going to load a model
So remember that the component of
type of suspense in this case because
we can pass a fold in this case it goes
to be a good kind of aunt [ __ ]
reactivate fiber and we are going to spend a
physix type component in this case this
physix type component comes a
This library is interesting because it is
written in Rose and thanks to
roe and we can use a website later
inside physics we are going to add
our first model that is going to be called
in this case Ale what is the court
After that I'm going to add a component
of bug type So that they can see the
colliders that we are going to add and
we are going to add in this case our
orbi Controls to be able to move the camera
so
We save here and if I have to recharge
So if you notice here Here
we have the camera so that
little yellow what do you see? That collider is and
well there we have the field now well
What is a game if we Pins and without the
ball So let's load our
pin type component here basically
I'm going to need a key for this kit
I have to tell me when I have
I have to restore the Pins after that
let's pass a type component to
know if the ball has already fallen so that we can
validate Well, if the ball has already fallen and well
What do you think they have fallen and we need a
event that gives us back the pines that
They have fallen ready So ​​if they give
account here at the end are the Pins and
If you notice the Pins have some
positioners But hey play a
finished, we need to add because our friend
Player then this friend Player who
he needs he needs the turn first
it's over. Then we pass a component
Torres end then he he need
also if the game is already over then
we passed our Game Over type event
and he also needs in this case a
event that tells us the ball has already fallen
So we pass it here in this case
How are we going to manipulate the camera? I'm going to
remove the concrete Controls then
here we keep And we have This then
If you notice I'm moving the ball
and now we're going to throw the ball strike
strike no no strike so in
in this case how can you realize Ah
He told us that we voted eight Pins let's go one
expert some dogs yes wait I'm very
bad at this but
Oh well
It's very boring to play alone So
let's quickly add a user
Let's give you, for example, that this
Call María, let's change the value
the color to the ball because well in the
themselves because it is not always good and
Let's play against a vote So
let's say this is a vote
So
because well a human is going to play and he is going to
play a pot we are also going to do this one
pass the color So for example that
This is a Blue and that's it. So now
since those properties the component
He has to know. So we tell him what.
We make out the smell and what does that mean?
we do then the game state that has
Well the game is basically there
We take your turn and tell you with this
value and with this he has the value of
this and now here we change it to
know if it is a Bot basically and this
Bot we put it here So yes
We reload here, see that the ball is now
blue come on strike
I didn't always throw strikes but I don't know
what happened now but oh well
now now Here we are going to launch This one there
I did it on purpose I know there would be
could and now he's going to play alone So
there like he's thinking he says I'll move it
I move it here, this is better than
I don't
So in that case how can they be given?
count because there we are playing I'm going to
show them above how it's done
this we are going to see our court our
court basically that we have we have
a model and we have a series of
coliders
are defined What are the values
that in which in this case some
Player has to collide the other
model the model at the end of the day
It's also a sexy day and this is
interesting because I can, for example
document this part and see it gone
the televisions we can in this case
also customize the day of sex you
At the end of the day a model comes that
comes from glb which is a format for
3D graphics After that we have
our Pins that also basically
It's a at the end of the day it's a pin here
I could even remove this one and know the
number of the Pins and here basically
we have a regi Boy those that you
have handled Unity here that is used
Something similar we have a ribbody and it does
councilor I go and we can add a
collider the default collider here is
type is to say I don't have to in this
case because it was not necessary and for
our friend Player who is a little
more complex if you realize
Here we do have
ribody This is a collider type
Ball and here we pass the ball ready and
as I showed you in the previous example
A Just frame is being used and here
because with the Just frame you control the
ball movement is controlled
also the the the position of the camera
anyway then this is a very example
faster than what can be done with
reactifiber So how can they be given?
account the handling of physics the handling of
states that you realize this
This component is a component with GS
normal that is rendering to doom
But what a pity that it can be connected
directly a component with ready
so basically it is the demo that
I wanted to show and to finish
those who want to play the game
It's almost finished, I'm missing the
gameplay in realtime that is to say
two users can play using sockets
so for those who want it
play
conclusions first learning
these new of these technologies to
through the use of breakable toys is
fun and challenging the other is It is
It is advisable to start with something simple
iterating little by little in the
knowledge is not going to be launched into
make a billiards I wanted to make a
billiards at the beginning No I still didn't play
first then learn and have the
established knowledge something very
important this type of applications
games are not exclusive to Ría, true
we are using reactive but also
initiatives to be able to use freedo
cold or even without vanilla library
You can also do the other thing before
starting with fiver is because
advisable to familiarize yourself with since
the same concepts are used
is being presented as an option
viable for the development of very games
logically simple when you want
make more complex games already exist
engines like Unity a real or even
for the web example facer
some documentation the documentation of
today is the reactivar documentation
some courses I highly recommend
last school year
that explains everything to us, there is even a
chapter to reactivate Well, nothing is
It was my talk, I thank you very much for your
attention
[Applause]
I was playing now it's great
but this game is bad because because
I can't vote any Oh I didn't tell you this
in beta
Hey son I believe I believe that
Yeah
Hey another hug
[Applause]
Hear that
very very grateful for your talk
we wanted to do some consulting
How do I do that but in Flash it is not
possible now
with the issue that it is no longer possible
doing it in Flash that takes us to the
Question: Is there anything Flash you use?
of
you miss three today but so
we replace
I'll pretend I understood
That's good. Thank you very much again.
hug
[Applause]
here here is a little peanut data
peanut data is like the crumbs that go
leaving yes Jorge no we don't want you
withdraw yet please stay
come with us there is something very special about
everything with Jorge here that Jorge participated
in the first and hides Colombia as
speaker we are talking now
We are talking about it and the one from Colombia
is going to celebrate its tenth anniversary
then that good energy that
you delivered in Yes with Colombia and that
Maybe it was like a command or something
style
yes whatever you have done please leave it
Here too so that we can
turn ten years old too please like this
that now yes Now yes that yes Now yes
teacher please thank you very much
[Applause]
Hear announcements before we go up
our next speaker that we forgot
to say
no vaporizers or cigarettes allowed
nothing electronic in here that I pull
odors or that bothers those nearby
If it's the Esplanade, like no one
problem but inside the theater please
let's avoid it no smoking
regardless of how so that no no
it is possible but nothing can come out there is no
no problem
workshops Yes there is an advertisement with the topic
of the workshops we had a small
technical failure and a child flew past
our project
So that projector Well not anymore
it's like this we're not fixing it
but it's not really a problem
it's going to be moved to tomorrow
but we are going to send an email to those who
the orchards were already subscribed for
be able to update information about
When are they going to be executed because there are
some itinerary changes of those
themselves for what happened to that child and
its laser beam
Hey not that completely So wait
wait for that email and it will arrive
now now we get on the plane
we left latin america
We are no longer in Chile, we are going to
amsterdam that because our
our next little talk is coming
direct from amsterdam a flight
more or less it stuck yeah then
I want to order a
gigantic
applause we're fine I'm not going to fill in
a bit
Now I do want to ask you for a round of applause.
to receive a gif It's good That's good
[Applause]
[Music]
yes goat caught
Hey before you do anything
introduction tell you that you are
songs are chosen by
talkers perhaps we had not
mentioned before but eh a little for
relax because just as
nerves talking in front of so much
people Look, he's already up there people Yes
Hey that then
the same
Greetings But that's because they do recognize
some of the songs can
suddenly talk to them that's the one
entry link with that they do
I like it too, I remember how it is
call this
somewhere we share it with
audio people then
intro gif is a
currently working in development
website for more than five years building
tools and products that help
generate to scale businesses I am a
cloud fanboy
Here is an anecdote with which I already have
I have a Walmart tattoo now and
cloister tattoos
But that goes to work with a lot
fronten development and now works on
relations levels and loves to talk
about web content Yes and the topic about
In general, the ticket system
that was used in the and the entire system that
there behind the Jet home was built
by lamb members and everything is
posted and running via
classroom and it has not fallen Thank you
applause
[Music]
[Applause]
applications
I'm just like
here familiar
[Music]
traditional
data data
terminal
[Music]
Spotify
flexibility city
[Music]
No thank you
[Applause]
I'm sorry
Hey
now yes
as you know
This is sometimes complex the issue of
organization we are organizing things
[Applause]
[Music]
combination for you
Your license
[Music]
I have
Lawrence
and
[Music]
applicational
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
applause
[Laughs]
[Applause]
[Music]
In Chileans they say half a poop
things that happen as Julián says
Hey
mistakes Comets one Learn from
the mistakes in the entertaining part is
like the professional growth of a
computer scientist one Learn from mistakes
some put the a classic I updated
all Power from the database does not
everything good Everything good Hey I hope not
It has been very very terrible indeed
new forgiveness
because if not I'm going to turn around on this
same topic
we are no yes
I believe that since this happened to us we have
to see a way to pass the pain now
true I don't know how but let's give it Let's go
Italy to travel from this now I believe
that our pocket gives us nothing
complex is complex I want but it is
complete and if we bring ourselves to Italy
Chili
It seems to me it seems to me So
we introduce the following
[Music]
speaker miquel hey we are really
set a little thing
but but before that I have a
little gift
calm down give me a second
it wasn't here it was here
What is
that
Oh good good
and this one they are not
They let us do nothing up here
They are giving that away out there Hey yeah
they want to take advantage I mean because if
they manage to start eh
we've been running a bit then
We really haven't been able to try
these little things out there the guys from
software have a space take advantage of
go steal one that is super rich and
in fact this is also a reminder
for just as we just
retar is not eaten or drunk inside the
true theater
that our next speaker is coming
directly from Italy it is a software
Google
Microsoft God How many acronyms
is working on sexually
and has is building an engine
search for a Time Script called
there in the background I see raised hands
Thank you
So I can ask you for a strong one.
very very very but very strong applause for
Michael we placed
[Music]
This brought me back
Milan East
Let's do a Hey, everything works fine.
benefits
[Music]
one last hug and we leave Google
[Applause]
[Music]
varying
particular leader after we from this is
OK
pass supermones
Facebook
[Music]
collaboration Which created
declaratorble declarators online
[Music]
matters
[Applause]
[Music]
Well there are some things there are some
things or conversations that one says to me
I would love to have known for three months
before yes three months ago there could have been
solved so many problems
and Michael Michael Michael
[Applause]
really
It wouldn't have been much use to know this
the last reflectors yes especially in
the development of the platform
tickets
is that it has been a no longer matters a
madness but they are anecdotes that later become
they are going to tell on the blog
They are going to enjoy it, it is part of
well the day continues with the talks
they continue the process continues and today
we have to introduce David
someone someone has heard
Thank you very much A point occurs here
da David is a Google developer and
works for the firebase team
Who here has used firebase in
something
[Laughs]
wow wow i'm surprised
we had this discussion so much now
back with Ricardo is not super popular
that is, user role management Hey
important to tell you about David that David
He has been learning Spanish for a year Yes and he is going
to give his talk in Spanish so
Hardcore Yes
that applause has to sound very loud
because it is something that usually
the people the latinos actually
When are they going to make it international?
They have to do it in English So
entertaining to see the counterpart Yes yes and
after a year of learning Spanish
because Well it is not a native language
so really on what up now
I ask you for a huge round of applause for him.
yes please and David
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't know about you but when I hear the
word error I start to feel a little
novel Maybe a star a little
embarrassed sometimes he looked around alone
to prove that it was not me who committed the
mistake
But why don't I even feel that way?
in the world of web development I find
which is the easiest place with most common
to make mistakes and without
performance
I have a question about performance
web for all of you how fast of
upload your website
three seconds no no no
right now you might be thinking
not two seconds no not a second but
none of the answers are wrong and
none of them are wrong
web performance has news because
There are many factors that determine the
metrics that are useful metrics
when running a test
performance even from there is
difficult to understand what stress means
metrics and how to fix those errors
I mean look at this traffic
what is happening here
there are many lines and numbers How can we
make sense
My name is 16 a lot About learning
of the errors Not because it is a
web developer who has broken a site
but because I'm a gringo
you can probably hear that the
Spanish is not my first language
when all I do is make mistakes
I have seriously been learning Spanish
For a year when I started I hated
talk because I couldn't finish one
prayer without making a mistake Even today
in day
I still get frustrated when when I use was
the place of fire was a place of being
But no one can improve by avoiding their
mistakes
Over time I realized that I don't know
try to avoid mistakes but
except them to improve in any
thing you just need not only you need
make mistakes but surround yourself with a
culture of learning from them now now
I have amazing friends and teachers
chile Argentina Brazil Bolivia Mexico
Colombia Uruguay Venezuela Costa Rica
Ecuador in many other countries when
Eat bullfighters I can hear myself
and improve faster than before
learn from performance mistakes
web is no different
today we are going to talk about performance
website and some common mistakes that everyone
we commit and how to learn from them
The first mistake I want to talk about is
ask the question how quickly should
keep my place
This question has a flaw it is unique
that there is a standard for different or
proof the websites are
different and users visit the
sites in different conditions a blog
static is different from an editor
graphics and 5g is much faster than 12
an aesthetic blog may not need
javascript at all while
graphics linker uses it quite a bit.
4G visitor
can deal with just 50 milliseconds of
latency and a 12 user could suffer
a full second to get there and
lap
This table describes the data rate that
are achieved in ideal conditions
sit in a parking lot
underground is not ideal but it happens to us
to all this means that the
network conditions which users
exceed in their place are derivable
network conditions when
adjusted results in delivery times
page load drastically
different, let's say a user has
visited with 400 kilobytes wide
band but a 100 milliseconds of
latency another visitor also has
400 kilobytes of bandwidth but a
1000 milliseconds latency
It is exactly the same place but just
only the latency that is easy When
you are in a parking lot increases
document upload 3 times Then yes
the warning alone can change
dramatically the page loading of the
same place it makes sense to ask what
so fast should my site load
the developer can control it
what network a user enters what
means that it is not about knowing a
solid number on which that load your
place
it's about knowing
that your page loads a spectrum of
different times at different
conditions the only way to know
this is measuring
This brings us to another common hero who
are you asking? There are so many. There are so many.
metrics to track and can be
overwhelming trying to make sense of it
What happens when a user makes a
request to a server to load a
website
the closer returns an html document
The browser starts the process
resource discovery
the browser searched
external widgets like style sheets
images and javascript like these
This is a waterfall chart
I show all loading resources
the page always starts with a
document
This document contains resources that
browser needs to load
you've probably noticed that there are bathrooms
steps for each part of the load
page time until first python
in English
the culture with the greatest content
the regulatory design change
and first entry delay
They are performance indicators each
of these metrics tells us where
locate a potential problem
is a set of metrics focused on
the user they focus on
real world experiences is
It is important to understand that excelling at
one metric does not guarantee success in another
page load is not unique number
but a spectrum of metrics that
show the performance of a site in
a moment at a given moment under a
set of substances
statistically one of the most important metrics
difficult to optimize is the adventure
with larger content or the SP
and this is a mistake we all are
committing
the lcp measures when the block is loaded
larger visual content in one
viewport you can think of this
as the hero element for many types
of pages
According to the http web study, 72% of
the pages have an image like
lock lct
I work at Google on the phase team and
I was one of our own page for
measuring the lcp Chrome tells us that it is
image is the content of lsp and when
you look at it it makes sense because it is one of
the most striking part of the page
interesting thing about this page is how
the image is loaded
look
here we can see the content and the
page styles are loaded
in exactly three seconds though
the image does not load until four
seconds
let's take a look at the waterfall chart
the document is loaded first
then the leaves of exile
style sheets load the Font by
end load the image
the s&p happens here but not why here
because that's why the image is not too much
heavy it is 40 kilobytes
when the browser tries to render
the initial document there are two processes
different ones going on the first one is
html parser this process reads the html
and creates the gift every time it is found
a locking resource such as a sheet
style should stop and wait for it to
process if this was the only process that
the browser runs alone could
request assets one by one and that
it would be very slow then while that
passes another process called
preloaded scanner or in english
reload scanner read document
to find any external resource
so we don't have to be blocked
by the html parser the browser is
assigns a to a resource external to the
resources blocking rendering
They are normally discharged
high priority
although the images block it
rendering the browser also tries
Designate a high probability to the
images in the viewport what
it is clear here is the is that the
browser should quickly discover the
lcp content and load it load it
soon as possible
here the image is marked as low
probability Although it is obviously in
the viewport Then
what are you using
well the problem is that the image is
lazy loaded
with an attribute in the tag
image
despite despite being the block
most important content for s&p su
loading is intentionally delayed This
causes the browser to assign them a
low probability at first I felt
a little embarrassed by this mistake
I mean how many more people are
doing also they are doing this or
expect 18% of all websites
captured by webnac report that
lazy loaded an image
lsp that's 18% of the 8 like 36 million
of sites around 1.5 million
sites that make this mistake
So how do we fix it?
the burtum can be removed so that the
image no longer lazy loading
although that will solve most
of the cases it is important to carry out a
monitoring the probability of
lsp image
In many cases the browser will still have
than loading other mining assets
important first
this is found on the label
main or before in the document
however we can tell the browser
that the image is important with a new
merge called priority hints
or in English
the testing suggestions are a
attribute on elements like images
java tags style sheets
There are even frames that tell the
browser that is important is the
speech with three values ​​high low and
automatic
We know that this image is ours
image the fp So we must make sure
that the browser also knows
Let's take a look at the load
page after anyway occasions
Before our lcp was 4 seconds but
now three seconds is an improvement of one
second
property suggestives are a great
tool
To finish the creator called them a
cheat code for SP
However, how many people are
using according to report
only zeal like 03%
. that means that 8 as unions of
sites could use the suggestions of
priority to improve performance
all this is just so that the image is
load and be visible on the screen but
Even when we do it quickly
there may still be a problem
Even if you don't know that the change
cumulative design you have definitely
gone through this experience
you are going to click a button and then
suddenly the button moves away and you click
in an advertisement
There are many reasons to change the
design but one of the most mistakes
common is an easy solution
one of the most common problems for
design change comes from
the images
when you don't give it an image tag
a height or width can make the
layout scrolls when browser
is rendering the page will not be able to
render the image at the beginning because
It is an external resource
ideally download the browser
the space occupied by the image to
keep the design intact but not Yes no
the height or width is specified in the
image food
How often does this happen
72% of the mobile pages surveyed
At least they lack attributes of height and
width In image tags that is
more than 6 million pages
This is a mistake we all make
committing again
Now we are going to focus on what happens
after he takes care of the document
html but how can we see in the graph
waterfall if we could speed up the
document loading speed then
everything laughs much faster
However of all the letters that
We have seen today one of the most
snapshots is the time until the first
byte
The time to the first byte measures the
time between browsing to a site and
the first batdata
has probably had problems
to improve there are many reasons reasons
for this but I'm going to focus on the
sentence in some cases we cannot
avoid connections with high latency
all users will have a
good connection
however we can help with the
latency through use
Delivery Network
cdn to cache our
global content
It is a network of servers around the world
which works as a cache in front of a
central origin server
when a user requests a site
first it will go to cdn edge server
If the nightstand has the contents
devours the user by serving a
fast answer
if the content is not on the server
King in Villarreal the request to
central region server for
retrieve or generate the content
the t-shirt can be used for
specify how long it can be
that content in the cache memory
server
The header works in three parts
visibility
browser cache and cdm cache
most interesting part is the directive
shared cache what it tells the server
How long should you store the
content
This is where you can create
a storage strategy that
keep the content in the cache
as long as possible before it is
need to recreate it in the
server
the surprising thing about the cdn is the
profitable and accessible that have become
For example
when deploying static websites on
Hosting the entire website is stored on
the cdn without the need for any
additional confederacy and there are so many
others who do the same a strategy
caching can be
difficult to develop but once
Doing so can have a massive effect on
all loading themes
of the page
This brings me to our next mistake.
How to know if any of these changes
is working
you need to measure there are two categories
main tools
synthetic performance and
real user metrics
tools like lighthouse are
synthetic because They run your site at
through a set of contracts in
simulated passions are surprising
to quickly view regressions or
improvements during development and before
implement the introduction however
they do not capture metrics from real users
As I said, I work on whether we have a
Ram service called
and after configuring a Script
we collect
automatically load metrics
the page from the browser this is
Metrics are collected throughout the
time to show you the trends
performance
not only the load metrics of the
page but also see which countries
users come from and what types of
connection they have when loading their site this
It is important because it is data from a
real user and we can use them to
use them to understand what is happening in
our site on our sites and do
best questions
With this information it could be
specific questions like when
our content appears for the first time
time for 13 users
Track those metrics in life
real allows you to see what type of user
are affected and what is the trend
Over time now I can see
with this question
that most users have at
least a 4G connection or higher but
41% of all users come with
speeds 13 and load in two like 24
seconds and that is much better than
ask how fast should my charge
place
before I leave I want to leave you with him
last error this error could be the
most important for everything of everyone too
when it comes to improving the
web performance it is easy to see these
improvements as if only
fixing bugs
fixes an error and now the page is
great fast charging
however the performance is much more
what arrangements
performance is a chatterbox and should
must be shared by all
team members if performance does not
is in the team environment
inevitably reduces all
Teams must know the metrics of
Real page load on should
encourage sharing mistakes when
the discover the errors are the way
in which we learn and advance I know that
Have you focused on web performance or if
He's just a gringo trying to learn
Spanish
Thank you very much to all
[Applause]
wonderful david
No, don't take it off, no.
in a moment with us
Hey you walked away too fast
Hey nowadays a lot happens that is
necessary to know them
I need to change English it's too much
I have two dogs and I like apple
[Laughs]
everything everything good thank you thank you
In other words, nowadays everything has to be known
go for analytics to improve
and it is really very necessary in fact
We wanted to ask you what it has been like
the best thing about learning spanish yes we are
curious about that which has been the most
Did you like learning Spanish?
to people of course
culture culture
Hey no, I really wanted to tell you
thank you because it doesn't usually happen that
someone come the other way to a
talk in Spanish that and now we
We are going to have lunch and you can calculate that
time to First Fight Yes yes
I see here
Yeah
very funny
Thank you so much
now we leave you free
guys don't leave for a second
second
we have to make a small announcement
and the other as a reminder actually the
first the announcement is that we need
that the vehicle with patent jgw y41
move your vehicle from where it is because
is washing an exit is blocking
a little bit already enough Hey that
we are going to go to lunch and
we will return in an hour we will
leave OK So let's all leave
the talks again turn before
one hour please let's send
reminders out but before a
time let's go back that's on
freedom of action Thank you very much
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
it has been it has been you if you have not seen
running I mean has been quite a bit
entertaining, yes it has been marathon but
not super entertaining so I imagine
that they were hydrated and everyone ate
some pancito took advantage of
rest we are very true Yes we are
well ready
a toy new toy
There is a There is a node project that is
Call Note Copter in case any time
They buy some drones and there are some APIs
to run not to run helicopter me
I mean drones with node and they are more
entertaining than anything else
look before we start we have something to do
announce
You throw it all away, I throw it, give it, don't
already
[Music]
as in any event in general when
are also massive, certain events occur
events that are sometimes outside of
our control
and on this occasion a topic of
Logistics
[Music]
projectors and it got a little complicated and
We try to solve it as soon as possible
possible and I hope it has not affected
Neither is your experience today.
We wanted to apologize Yes together
So under their chairs there are
tomatoes
apologize about that and well
we want to make a space together
with this drone to live the moment
here at So we want to ask you if
is that when this drone goes up
very high until
And what do we have to do when
come over there take a shot let's go
take a shot
like in a giant perspective So
I do not know how
the name and everyone raise their hands
and power I don't know
give a giant round of applause to you
also that they are here
one two three
[Applause]
beautiful beautiful
If you throw it there I'm going to cut it
someone's hair
and after this Passionate moment with
the drone
Thank you, teacher
tell you that in the talk now
we castled
because you will be able to see all that
we had to install and then
taking it out was like no if we move it here
yes no we don't want to break anything then
we generate a castling between tallison and
Charlie So Charlie is the one who's going to
leave
next to us now yes And we have to
make the presentation
of the travels of the beginnings
most chaotic conference I have ever seen
I ever go to a conference
I mean I came out it was almost on the verge of not
arrive yes They canceled flight three
Sometimes we have to change the airline
search today in the morning does not pass the
hotel
But it arrived okay I think I think
he slept some I think I think he had lunch
But that So we're going to have a
quite entertaining chat with Charlie
true and yes And it happens to me that
I love the talks the talks
Charlie and Arath find it very
motivational and very inspiring
in the things that can be done
made in the European Union in 2019
made the talk with the sensors in the
head to be able to move the keyboard and
easy as written everything with Java madness
total madness
before being okay with all this so
Yeah
we are enjoying it quite a bit
So I want to ask you if you can give
a little applause, not a big applause,
scandal please because of the chaos that occurred
and to receive it on stage for
Please if you can Charlie
[Applause]
[Music]
great movie The first O the
second you like the third fourth
Which one is the favorite first?
it's working no
proof
we have a backup it's working
now no no let's see for a second
castling for this
one two one two three
Hey
It makes chaos but it still looks like
anecdote and then one laughs at these
moments
and we go
[Applause]
Thank you
It sounds like I'm doing karaoke now.
It sounds like everything is related to
my trip has been chaotic so I want
prepare them so that everything can go well
this talk let's go good vibes well
Ok before I start with the topic of
iPad I am Charlie drone developer
senior and as part of my role I work in
typical of albece that created resources
so that developers know how
use our products and other parts
my role
found in another company is that
strike has Open source samples that
people can clone to start
quickly and develop seven
languages ​​So I keep all that
So I develop a script but you write
so it's like a very part
interesting my work the last one is
more personal that relates this
talk is that I can choose a topic
technology that interests me and explore it
And if it is related to a strike of any
great way and if not I still can
share knowledge with
community because stripe is a company
of technology and we don't know where they can
all the ideas come and that is very
interesting Although perhaps not
My work is related to
quotation marks
I wrote the book
practical Machine learning in javascript
and I push the frontier of what I can
do and more specifically on the network and
also generally trying to use
technology for things I don't do
I work so I explore strange things
So what is life
Life is a technology that uses
light source to transmit
information, can I get it? Yes, that's great.
So what we're going to do at the end
This table, what you should understand is that
something like this should be done there is a light
to the left that flashes and commands
data to the light sensor on the right and
what happens in the
browser that opens a link that is
strike thing at the end of The Talk
They must understand how to send a
link a small light to a sensor and
do something in the browser This is the
meta works fine when I do it in the
home and when I travel it didn't work very well
so let's see Even if the demo fails the
concept I think you can understand it
So if we see the spectrum
electromagnetic and with this beautiful
image that I made and we already use waves
radio waves to communicate the type
wave with which wi-fi works and is
transmits data from the router via
radio waves received by devices
from the internet and then see it on the
screen when the device
decode
the transmissions we are now trying
to use another part
of the electromagnetic spectrum light
visible can be used infrared
but for this talk it is better if
can you see something so let's use light
visible more Precisely it is a light that
is on a safe frequency, you can
use laser if you want But here yes
it's that they shoot lasers into someone's eye
can be dangerous so let's
use normal light the purpose of
iPhone is to use devices that already
they have the light from the environment for example
From the stage light in the office So
how can they use light to
transmit the data if we think about the
lights here or lights on the phone
There are two states, it is on or off.
If you have RGB you can use that with a
color sensor may have different
states green can be something blue can
be something but here they use the sensors
of light the only everything of states that go
to matter is on or off
to experiment
data via light here I am not going to use
bulb but I'm going to use an LED
here I am going to show you in the
screen we are going to use two arduinos
controllers that can program a
little in javascript and 23 components like that
that it doesn't take much to
experiment with this too
schematics here the configuration
the light is transmitted above
which will flash the encoded data
Below is the trap with the receiver that
It is a light sensor that makes the SAT not
They see it so much on the slide but there is something
transparent that looks like an LED an LD
but it's a light sensor a bit
transistor we have all components and
We know that it is possible to send data via
light But how do they do it How do they go from Him
Hardware to make it work first
part is to encode the data there is
something but how they do it from one end to the other
a fact that is basically lights
considering that we only have two
states of a light on off
we can consider that one is turned on
and zero off
and how computers work at the level
lower in binary because in binary
there is only one and zero and with the
light on off
How would they send the letter h masking
as a decimal
its value 72 is suddenly the number that
represents a letter in binary is 0 1 0
0 1 0 0
we go from h to binary and we can
use that to include the state of
the light in light status would be off
on off off on
off off off that for the
transmitter but it is not all too
are the light detection sensors
as a receiver to detect changes
of light and convert that to aski back
if we only send one source
constant of ones and 0s as we ensure
that the light sensor on the other side is going to
be synchronized the right way
so that nothing or a bit is missing
Let's imagine that we are going to send
constant flow of hs they send it
repetitively, such as
words and phrases but it is easier
same letter over and over again so that
see it can start we already know that
a character is a byte and a beet is 8
bits So you can imagine that
can take a bit sample every 8
bits and converts it back to
decimals and aski But what if the sensor
light starts detection a little
delayed Maybe due to a failure or had a
Back or was interrupted for some reason
takes 8 bit sample but location
mistakenly may think then that the
another bit you have to decode is 1
0 0 1 0 0 0 0 but it is not a character that
exists So the rest of the data is
converts badly because it is going to take samples
of other bits but starting the
location in the data stream as
we make sure everything is synchronized
regardless of whether you have the correct text
and that can read synchronously this is
where it becomes more interesting so
less for me because we have the
opportunity to create our own
general communication protocol
I guess no one in this room had the
opportunity before creating the protocol
because many times it depends on
another that were created as tcp http
maybe and we no longer create protocols but
when experimenting with a rapid prototype
iPad can think more
Deep as binary data is
errands sent AND decoded
We then create the protocol
communication and this is where I hope
They are not in the digestive stage of the
lunch because I need you to focus
very easy to explain and I hope it does
good job on this and make it clear
If they are sleeping I will lose them
but we hope that we don't expect that
are awake
so normally there are many ways
other than creating a protocol
communication that's why it's cool
experiment with this because I'm going to
tell me one way and then another friend
gave another idea. There are many ways to
do it but to start perhaps with a
data to identify the beginning of the
message here we are going to call it a
synchrony word or preamble followed
for raw data one byte and then
It's like the header between the preamble and
the raw data sometimes there is some type
of
post or a check all symbol
It depends on how they design the protocol.
communication here we are going to maintain it
simplest possible let's just
have a bit that indicates that a
message and then the 8 bits and then
at the end a final bit that sends the light
back to its original state so that
the protocol can be repeated Ok yes
we are integrating this as part of
a light a bulb we know that when
the light bulb is off
sending nothing when they think this
technology in your home when when
turn off the light they are not doing a
streaming are sleeping
suppose there is a constant zero of
any way so it won't be
decoding nothing we don't want
decode something If the light is
always turned off on the other side if it is
on can be on for
lighting a space does not mean that
it is automatically sending data
Because it's on
but more likely he is sending
data when it is on because they are
the light so let's start with the
assumption that the Light will be
On I have been by default that
on So it's number one if the
default state is one has to
there is a change to indicate to the receiver
something is coming as a message is about
If sent we can have a sensor
light that checks the brightness level
around it constantly and a
time it detects that it was turned on and off
the light
you can start sampling
data the original state is on
the light and once it goes down it has turned off the
receiver says Ah I think there's a coming
message here for example we have a
graphic representation The preamble
the light going off and then on
off every 100 milliseconds is like a
unreal message
It's like 1010 but that's easier
explain it this way on the side of the
receiver stops sampling once
that the data goes out because it's like
a sign that indicates that the
message the first time you take a sample
the receiver waits 150 milliseconds
because we don't want to know the value of
preamble because simply the message
that warns that a message is coming
This matters so much because it is not part of
data is added 50 milliseconds
because I want to make sure that when
the sample is taken we are within the
interval where it will be on
turn off the light if the light goes out
turns on and there are a few microseconds of
difference they do not want to sample the
wrong data
In this way the first sample gives the
number one because the light is on
subsequently 100 seconds because a
time it synchronizes with the first 250
They can use interval like that of
transmitter
So the second sample they are going to give
zero because now the light is off and
the code is repeated for the 8 bits in a
byte
finally when the byte is sent
complete ends with a postcard that
The light sends it to its original state.
are using light in an environment if
is that it goes up and ends with a zero and no
they turned on the light means that I was going to
turn off your own light that's not what
They really want to turn it back on.
gives you this cycle to repeat for each
country if they are sending another
character starts by turning off the light and
then send the Beat in the state of
on off and then back on
on giving all the bytes that
it has to work this is the theory in
this point is how i think it could
work but don't write the code like
you see the code to do this first
there must be a binary letter and then this
you can do it in classic javascript
We are going to use
To add this let's say we want
say in code the word hello hello
We are going to divide the streaming into
different characters and for character
adding zero is for the decimal value
hera 70 I think the 2 is used to have
the binary equivalent and we are
adding to ensure that if the
byte
they end up multiple zero is going to remove them and
ends with a byte that only has
5 values ​​long and that would be horrible
For the protocol we want to ensure that
each country has 8 bits even though
the first ones are zero and then
we put i in to create a String
end so at the end the word
would end up in a String of zeros and ones
very good
This is for cool data conversion
Now we have to transmit the data AND
like this is a javascript conference
let's do it in javascript So let's
use Johnny Five if you have never used
this frame before is great I recommend it
It's fun to do things in
arduino in javascript too and another
ports and other sensors and they are all the
what am I using let's use
this
First you have to configure the board
remember the packages
they need and have to define the
variables
the pin is the light that is connected to the
arduino can be pin 7 But it can be
the one you want from 0 to 13 for the
digital pins in interval 100
milliseconds that I mentioned that well
String that must be sent and then the
Script will be the variable that maintains
the object for the light and then we create
the word with the port and with the
arduino to which it is connected to
computer we have two different ports
But that's for the next step.
So before writing the logic for
connect and control the Hardware I have
to see the communication protocol and
understand Ok what he has to do
transmitter has to understand sorry
you have to turn off the light for him
preamble and then you have to see the
bits and say light on off
Depending on the value and maintain
encerted and interval So how do I do
the interval
This is going to be the most hacked part
You can write better if you want.
wanna
delay the function then And that is
resolves after a certain milliseconds
and this gives a delay of 100 and this
function will try that javascript
be a little more synchronous because it has
It all happens one way
sequence specific and javascript not
It's so much for this but let's try
To achieve this there are other ways I go
to mention later but we are cast
So let's try to make it happen like this
form and then to logic we must
turn on the light turn it off is the function
here and then make a Loop through all
the characteristics that must be sent
We know that the first thing to do
by character it is to make the preamble
We turn off the light and wait in between
and then we convert the characters
specific in binary and for each bit
we are going to have a service function that
I will explain the following function
I want to finish this logic and This is going to
be turned on off Depending on the
value of the Pipe if it is one it will
turn on zero off and then on
the light comes back on once I send the 8
bits and here I am recursively
calling him back when I'm
testing things I want to send the
word Hello once only until
that she is happy
the previous plate the value in this case
It's going to be one if the light is on
on and zero if the light is off and
then applied the delay so that
stay or continue working every 100
milliseconds
well to put all this together we have
to return to the element we mentioned
at the beginning when the board is
ready for instructions here
We have our light and I tell you well
pin the led that we said at the beginning is
here the duration is 7 in the amount of
Led that I have in this component
particularly if you want to experiment with
this does not have to use has a
simple led and you have to change the
code a little bit but still the same
way it works this is ready and here
I'm turning on the light at the beginning
for
simulate that the light is on in the
living room for example then send the
message so I will keep an eye on it
for 3 seconds and then we will
configure the logic of sending data
So right now it's not like that.
When the code that I just gave them uploads
mention start doing this start
to flash and then we have that part
that he receives because up to here it is only
a light that is just flashing
let's move on So now the
decoding
now let's configure the second
board that is going to look very similar to the
first
We have here we have the pin it's a little bit
different because it is an analogue with zero
there are thresholds and the thresholds are going to be
different depending on the environment
your project is being generated if it is
It's dark So man can
be minor And how here this is going to be the
man more value higher forgiveness the most
high
to match the transmitter
and that again before implementing the
receiver I have to understand or Return to
protocol and see what it has to do
do first we have to detect
when the light goes out wait for the first
150 milliseconds and then have the value
which is delivered with the interval How to
does this first we have to know the
light status there is a small function
I'm going to
point out later that it is close
to the threshold close to one because of that
shape that implies that the light is
turned on at value 1 we have a
coding stance you have here
the condition because we know we want
start detecting messages when
the light is off and it was on
before That means then that there is a
preamble message coming and then
we can start to have the fusion of
bits and what this does So
we have an interval of 150,000 seconds
an interval
1.5 times larger than the previous one
we have the look that transfers and here
we have the ldr function that is going to
select or identify the value of the
light that is approaching zero Y
again So let's have a by
complete and here I am simply
having a mining agent who transformed
the bits and transforms them back into
a character
We have mentioned this in the process
reverse of what the transmitter is here
then it has bi They form aski and
This is better than what I did in the other one
address
then again when this board
ready
From the receiver we already have the sensor
sensor is ready
and we have the luminosity data Y
again generated the look for that shape
to code technically
It is one of 80 codes depending on the
project we have the transmitter and also
the receiver at both ends less than
80 elements for that shape create this
technology
now let's get to the part where
it could turn out bad for me
technology how they can be generated
communication a protocol
communication and implement it in
javascript
Now let's see if it works
I have to remember then here the
steps so first
warning because you have epilepsy
or you would feel the light caution because
here you will see flashes of light and you will
see the water is worth the light vatilar and here
It could be conflicting for you
Now I have to remember what it is
I have to do first let's go
That's my terminal, okay, I have to
connect
we have second
I connect the first connector also the
camera so that way when they are
far
I'm going to start a zoom meeting to
so people can see it too
is connecting
good
we join the zoom meeting
Because it does not connect
trust me
so it doesn't connect, you have to send it
I'll do it again in the morning
I also had difficulties, maybe
many things connected to my computer
the camera is not working
let's see the rest works
What do we have here first I have to know
the port, don't look at this, it looks horrible
but I have this port
So first we have to connect
and we will try
I have to
connect to the board the light stopped
it's flashing that's good good sign
and now I have to connect the second one
and in the second I have to go up
this data which is the second port is
totally working well
and the difficulty or issue here is that
the light is more intense than the
I will try to do everything about the LED
ways try to fix it
this is one of the most configurations
complex things that I have had to do
us is very intense in the
scenario Maybe they can download it
production
so what i want to do
is I'm going to have this I want to see then
what light value should
point as threshold
set me down for a second every time
I connect the ports on the computer
they change
one to see 104 I'm going to go to the transmitter
now
1 2 4 good
1 42 should now work
We don't have the transmitter here we should
see a little light
Now, do your job, it works.
I have to do it again now yes
Now I know what happened, I don't
I'm going to explain because I already know what happened
[Music]
I want it to blink again to see what it is
flickering
This is not the demo
seriously even worse than in the morning
now I don't know what it is
happening
why not
time is up
Well
I'm going to try one more thing I'm going to
disconnect and connect because just as
works
and that's what I'm going to have to do
see
now yes
I think I'll try
to flash or turn it on
from the other board. Let's see, well, yes,
works
It's throbbing I have a video Oh yes it is
Don't believe me, I have a video so
Don't think I'm talking pure
lies here
[Music]
Why change of port
one four four now
four four two zero one
what we have done now is that the demo
that I knew worked Now there it is
Now first of all turn on the light
one thing is working oh well one
thing at a time
But that's not even that but I didn't want to
do that actually But anyway let's go
with the second
because I need you at least
we go with the second and now we have the
first knowing that it was one four four
This is going to be the second Now here I go
to upload it
to connect with this
and it's going up what I want now is
have the correct threshold Establish a
the receiver is correct I want you to know